at the End of
Time 13
oock hey what's going on you guys H
we're always talking about funny [__]
like right right before the right before
the uh show starts and then like when we
come on we're like chuckling about what
is talking about well you know what I
mean you know when the intro happens
when the baby's hand comes up like that
yeah all right said said to Jen we need
to [__] change that to my dick coming
up like green light on it and see if
anybody notices and Jenny Jen's like
yeah we can't do it now because because
you just said it out now they all be
waiting for it well yeah don't make it
regular do it like once yeah just like
so nobody notices it and do it kind of
like do it kind of like what do they
call that subliminal yeah from a funny
angle so it's like subliminal like all
that like all those people that think
they see weird [__] in like murder
Hornets sitting around waiting for a
addict of
here it's going to be claiming that he
saw it [__] one of these days yeah and
yeah then like if we just like give the
suggestion like maybe people will start
seeing it instead of yeah I saw it I saw
it yeah cuz I love that baby hand every
time like every time we like hit the
intro thing I'm just like here comes the
baby hand I don't know why that like
amuses me so much but it does like every
single time I'm I'm a simple
person I'm easily amused obviously
[__] full hilarious [__] well yeah
it's gonna be a good case tonight I
think so too oh Zach says yay my
favorite show a that's so nice of you
that's so nice it's gonna be a good show
yeah we and actually Tom doesn't usually
do this but he actually sat and watched
all three episodes of the miniseries
yeah like the do miniseries that they
made about this guy back in 2021 that's
on Netflix which is called the raincoat
killer like he was sat there and we
watched the whole thing last night yeah
showed hooker Hill where where I used to
hang out Tom very familiar with hooker
Hill hooker Hill he he was hunting out
at Hooker Hill yeah yeah we're going to
talk about it we are going to talk about
that yeah they were showing Soul old
soul actually I don't really know a lot
of this shit's happening in around 2000
dur they had this spe like ear well
20034 2003 that time yeah yeah well in
2000 they had this big economic collapse
evidently around that time I wasn't
there you I was there in 1990
1991 so it was a different era evidently
it supposed to be like a good times in
for Korea when I was there said it got
worse it's probably made it comeback but
it seems to have that was the
implication from the show yeah but yeah
1990 was kind of like the Korean version
of the
80s yeah it was all like it was like fun
for them they liked that yeah it was all
fun but then making Mone and [__] as
always it's [__] starts going downhill
shortly
afterward now announce that we got this
uh partnership sponsored so yeah we have
actually started getting into doing
affiliate Partnerships hooray like I you
know I I kind of have been wanting to do
that kind of stuff for a long time so
our first sponsor SLA affiliate is good
old audible.com audible now you guys
know what AUD
is obviously um they it's the probably
the largest uh you know collection of
audiobooks podcasts blah blah on the
internet ch's got a lot of a matter of
fact almost all of my books other than a
couple of the graphic novels uh I have
them available on Audible uh that you
can listen to so you know if you guys
want to I know a lot of you have
listened to them but if you haven't then
you can absolutely go an audible and
listen to me talking about true crime or
paranormal cases or reading my horror
novels or or whatever and we actually
have an affiliate link right down in the
description box and if you click on that
affiliate link which obviously we get a
commission for then you will get a
30-day free trial of audible and that
includes one credit uh that you can use
to buy whatever you want on there that
you can keep forever actually if you're
already an Amazon Prime member you would
get two credits uh with this deal so
yeah yeah so you can get two of Jenny's
audio books there there we there you go
that's what you do there you go she's
got some good
like an unseen unseen hand which was
about a collection of poltergeist uh
stories going way back it's like one of
the biggest encyclopedias of them of all
these just weird cases she dug up going
way back how far back do you think they
go jent 1600s is it no way farther back
than that that okay that it goes back to
like ancient Greek times ancient Greek
times when it started okay yeah but then
there's a bunch of modern ones too that
are forgotten all through the 50s and
40s and 60s and 70s I so that's a real
good one and then uh a lot of True Crime
that she's done yeah my whole faceless
villain series is on there um most of my
horror novels are on there my short
story collections are on there so yeah
man uh you know if you want to listen to
them if you don't have an audible
subscription already like I said the
link is down in the description box you
just click that full disclosure we get a
commission every time somebody clicks
that link and you'll get at least one
free book yeah and you get a 30-day free
trial where you can listen to wherever
you want and there's podcasts and all
kinds of stuff on there too so yeah all
right audible do it do it yeah it's good
service all right it is good I you know
I I wouldn't I wouldn't um partner with
anybody that I wouldn't use myself you
know what I mean cuz there's a lot of
stuff out there that you can promote on
your show but most of it is
um
lame you know what I mean yeah cuz you
can go to like ClickBank and stuff like
that you can find all kind of stuff that
you can plug on your show but most of it
is junk yeah A's a good one though yeah
audio books and all kinds of stuff
podcast like I said I use that myself so
so it's a good
deal so yeah so like I said if you have
Netflix there is actually a documentary
about this guy I'm pretty sure please
correct me if I'm wrong pretty sure he
is South Korea's most prolific serial
killer in terms of number of victims not
saying cuz there's been other ones since
then and there was actually one that was
running around a littleit that
overlapped with this one a little bit um
but I think that guy killed only only 14
people this guy well he was convicted of
20 but he confessed to 26 I don't think
they could prove the other ones so they
didn't go with it but he was convicted
of 20 murders so at least 20 and I'm
pretty sure that there's more
this dude man it was it's a good
documentary too and there's like other
some other people have done some stuff
about him on YouTube but I think in
terms of numbers um he was the most
prolific well is he's still alive um but
he is the most prolific serial killer
and the weird thing about it they
mentioned this on the documentary too is
that he was very aware of his quote
unquote ranking in the serial killer
Stakes I guess big ego he wanted to be
the world's biggest I guess I mean you
know so I was like uh aim high I guess
he was trying to
impress yeah he was kind of one of those
and he's one of and this is really
common in serial killers too like he's
one of those guys that thinks he's like
smarter than everybody else yeah so made
him like a little bit insufferable yeah
he did he did other than all the
murdering that he did you know he did a
lot of [__] like oh when I tell you what
I did it's going to turn the world
upside down he thought everything he did
was blow your mind the biggest baddest
thing ever yeah the biggest [__] deal
ever um he was a dick but uh no there
was guys that were much weirder um he's
just real egotistical he's interesting
though uh kind of the thing that was
unusual about this guy is that his
murders didn't start off as having a
sexual motive but then later on they got
sexual he was the he was the kind of he
had issues all right I'll let Jen get
into him later yeah but uh he started
off killing people because of money uh
supposedly I think it was just kind of
pent up rage was part of it but then it
started to go sexual you know going
after hookers and stuff yeah he had uh
kind of a Jack the Ripper and I think
for a time and I'm going to say and they
went into this a great deal on the
documentary which like I said is
actually very good um that the police
actually got a A drubbing for the way
that they uh whiffed this case really
and a lot of them will you know ju will
straight up say that they you know
didn't handle it correctly which but I
do have to give them some slack because
one it was the early 2000s two see you
know their their uh their [__] wasn't
nailed down real tight they didn't
communicate with each other very well
stuff like that um there were some other
things like institutional things which
we'll get into they had really never
seen anything like this before uh they
knew of serial killers obviously like
from other countries and stuff but they
had really never
they it said we had murders and stuff
but it's like usually it was pretty
clear like who did it like it was pretty
clear what the motive was it was robbery
or it was of Love Triangle gone wrong or
something like that there was always
like a motive behind it they're like we
had never seen this kind of just
motiveless random yeah they had never
seen it and it's just kind of like so
they didn't really know what to do yeah
in Korea you they would wrap up they
could wrap up a murder in days with like
a 97% accuracy rate the Koreans you know
living there
the Koreans I compared to say westerners
or what I would call milk toast they
were milk toast they're kind of they're
not
violent and uh when they are violent
they're not real professional about it
they get caught it's usually kind of
heat of the- moment thing or just two
bit amateur gangster [__] you know
what I mean and they're kind of fake
gangsters compared to the guy to guys
that we have
here you know you hear about the Yakuza
up in Japan and [__]
and the those dudes are like nothing
compared to say like the Mexican Mob the
Mexican mobs are real outfit they will
really [__] you up and they're smart and
they get into the police or system and
they use police computers to find their
victims and [__] because their
girlfriends are working in there or they
turn cops and Top Cops join the damn
Narco armies because they they got all
the money they're really dangerous and
they kill you slowly you know Murder hon
sent me videos because he lives on that
border over there and he gets his hands
on some [__] bizarre ass videos where
they'll just take an enemy and Drug him
up with fentanyl and just skin him alive
with a knife you know and start
disassembling him while he's alive and
he's too he's on too much fentanyl to do
anything about it they're just
videotaping the whole thing they're not
scared they want everybody to see what
they do they they they they use horror
tactics judges are scared of them cops
will run from them when they see them
they got military TR and Equipment
they're bad there's nothing nothing like
that in Asia nothing and in Korea that
sounds nice actually yeah they're just
not well they're very peaceful they're
um homogeneous so they're all kind of
related to each other it's kind of like
a big extended family Korea China Japan
no they hate each other but inside their
ethnic groups they just kind of they get
along real well they're real polite
Koreans when I was there didn't even
have cussing they didn't have that
concept yeah our kusas which were Korea
Army argumentation United States Army
they were Koreans that would serve with
us in the US Army as
interpreters we'd be cussing and [__]
insulting one another and they had no
idea and when you turned it on them they
they they couldn't fathom it because
there's no cursing in Korean they don't
even have that concept takes them a
while to get to it they then but they
never quite learn how to curse I would
offend them every five
seconds like you know we call people a
[__] this and that [__]
and we had to explain to them this is
somebody who [__] their own mother and
I mean but that's not literally when
what you mean normally what curse is but
right that's what the curse is but
that's calling somebody that right but
when you use it you don't usually mean
that literally their heads AB be side
yeah that's very rude that's why they're
doing that you know cuz man if I talk
about somebody I don't like and I'll be
like oh this [__] like I don't
necessarily mean that they literally
[__] their own mother bad guy I'm just
saying yeah this bad person he's an
[__] he's an [__] that I don't
like could also mean very good though we
can use flip it around and make it sound
good that's a [__] right there
man give me that [__] see that's
the best thing about curse words is
they're so versatile you can use them in
all different kinds of ways so Koreans
were not
curs they're mostly Christian I think it
was I forgot which one it was which
denomination it
was but they do have some kind of like
Buddhist and kind of like traditional
beliefs kind of mixed in their Buddhism
is from another country that's foreign
to them but they had it for a long time
but they have something kind of like
Shino too Korean folk
beliefs but those aren't about God
really those are just about what you do
how do you how you handle the dead you
know philosophy traditions and [__]
little stories kind of like their
version of asap's fables or something or
you
know so um they don't have criminal
cultures in the same way America does
they just have kind of like
delinquents yeah drink and too much and
fight much and try to scam other people
but there are no real
hardcore dangerous organized crime and
they're just not used to that so
they they were it was shocked to them
when they realized that they had a
serial killer on their hands because
they were like man that's something that
happens in big yeah that doesn't happen
here po industrial type countries you
know what I mean who collaps and the guy
and they did imply because they talked
to like a lot of the law enforcement
that had worked on the case and a lot of
them are still like kind of are [__]
up about it which you know
understandably and the one guy said he's
like you know there were a lot of
murders in Soul I don't know what a lot
means like maybe a lot to him wouldn't
be a lot to us we're probably like what
okay that's nothing but it's like well
you know it's not nothing but I'm just
saying like in comparison
but he was saying oh there were a lot of
murders in Soul prior to that so they
did investigate murders it's not like
this was the first murder ever and they
didn't know what was going on but it was
just kind of like the murders we had
before that were easy to figure out um
you know they caught most of the people
immediately because it was you know it
was clear what the motive was yeah like
uh but they had never seen this kind of
like random yeah [__] before so they
didn't really know exactly how to deal
with it yeah I lived there for a
year and I liked the Koreans the the
Koreans were a trip they they were their
own thing uh they're not like the
Japanese they're not like the Chinese
they're kind of in between the two and
that they're physically located kind of
in between the two and they were in
between a hammer and an anvil for
thousands of years between a damn
Japanese empire and a Chinese Empire
constantly crushing them and trying to
absorb them into or enslave them into
their Empires and they just kind of
mostly remained independent they're just
kind of a
Fierce People you know uh but they're
big
into Concepts that are kind of out of
style by in American culture Concepts
like Purity they're a big end of that
and
innocence
uh it's just you know so they're very
kind of like almost
1950s you know G Wall-E you know like
they're like that you
know um but they're they're good people
like I said I would horrify them if I
was over there I feel like probably
maybe not nowaday uh well they like
foreigners they did when I was there
they the girls were
fascinated um guys not so much um guys
would probably there guys there would
probably check out a western guy Western
woman but they probably be intimidated
they're kind of wall flowery kind of
like in Japan slightly but then again
you got thugs there too you know you
never can't tell that's what I mean it's
like you can't just like blanket
generalize they not generalized it's
just average on average they're kind of
a shy people we actually have a listener
in the chat who is from South Korea
limle hello from South Korea how you
doing yeah he's a serial killer even the
profilers got spooked yeah they had the
profiler on there talking about it and
he was like I believe he was South
Korea's first profiler yeah and um yeah
they were all like all the dudes that
like investigated this case and the the
dudes and the women that investigated
this case they were just kind of like
they were really you could still tell
they were still [__] up about it
what's your name again Lim Lee l l Lee
Lee I lived in MIM gak north of the M
Jim River at a place called Camp Greaves
it was right behind Warrior base in the
JSA area almost in almost I could when I
was doing the DMZ
Mission you could you could see you
could almost see
Pyongyang from across the board from
what I remember or it was just a Korean
City it may have been may not North
Korean City may not have been pongyang I
forgot which one it was I don't think it
was but right there on the border when
we were doing the mission M Jim gek M
Jim River it's now a
museum the camp that I lived at uh uh
Korean school kids get to tour it
evidently so and they blew up all the
defensive uh bunkers that we had on the
right outside the DMZ they or on the DMZ
they broke they they blew them up as
part of some new
treaty so I only got to go to Soul
and and tomong Duan maybe once a month
so I was mostly working on that border
area and I wanted to see more of Korea
but I I I didn't have time and I was in
a high security
area so you could never meet any of
these girls these girls would like want
to get your phone number you didn't have
a phone to give them and you couldn't
call them you'd never see him again you
know right so um and you we were kind of
on under orders to not to make any kind
of friendships with South Koreans you're
not going to see them anyway and you
know the North Korean intelligence
agents might might be masquerading as
Korean civilians you don't know but uh
it was an interesting
time but um yeah that's that's where I
lived all right I got way behind on the
comments Zach says man I will always
have a special love for the faceless
villain because that was my workout
listing when I lost all the weight back
in 2018 oh that's awesome yeah yeah okay
uh then when I was talking about I
wouldn't have anybody sponsored in the
show that I didn't actually use or think
was cool TVD Dragon says sponsored by
big Peg strapon Emporium your source for
the world's largest selection of dildos
and select accessories get your holes
wet and wrecked big pegs strap on
Emporium hopefully that's a real place I
just gave him like a free a free plug
never live that
[__] it's going to take a lot of money
for me to make that video someone out
there has enough money to make this
happen you'd only have to do it once Tom
that motorcycle money what if a m what
if a billionaire came to you and said I
will give you a million dollars it it it
was it would be like that movie like
what was that movie called Indecent
Proposal where that rich guy like came
to Woody harelson and said hey I'll give
you a million dollars let me [__] your
wife yeah you know what I mean yeah it
wouldn't even take that much though I'd
probably do it for a well don't tell her
that new Harley that new Harley sportser
ass I'd probably do it for that or that
[__] you would give up your ass
virginity for the new Harley Sportster
okay that's a [__] hot looking Sports
St I didn't think I'd ever ride you're a
cheaper date than I thought Tom yeah
maybe maybe they maybe that Indian
[__] Indian Scout [__] bobber
maybe that one something like that
that's what I mean it's go to be
motorcycle money I ain't giving up the
ass like
that that [__] cost
money but you do have a you do have a
price everyone does you got to be
realistic you know what got to be
realistic that's really funny there's a
there is a price I mean [__] like I said
pretty well I mean up to a point I mean
there's some things that I wouldn't do
for any amount of money but um you know
[__]
[__] which kind of ties back into the
topic of today's show because he also
hated women that were sex workers so
there's that um yeah so they're talking
about uh prolific serial killers Camp
guy says killer nurses and doctors have
high body counts yeah I remember we did
a show about what do we call them like
quote unquote angels of Mercy killers
and he's talking about Donald Harvey I
thought we talked about Donald Harvey on
that show but maybe not maybe we
initially were going to but then we
didn't have time or something like that
so if we didn't talk about him then
we'll get around to it um but yeah so
hold on I got really all kinds of stuff
in there yeah I got really really behind
yeah very scary guy she says he had
something about uh women I don't know
the the word um yeah he he actually like
really really hated women which we'll
get into in a little bit that was one of
his main things but I think that for a
while because in the early 2000s and the
police in Korea had never really dealt
with a situation like this and because
the Dude changed MOS pretty
significantly like at he did like a
bunch one way and then he went to a like
slightly different area and did a bunch
like a completely different so I think
at first they thought it was two
different perss you know what I'm saying
but
yeah uh let's see yeah I look I got way
behind um Ben said remember that South
Park episode where too many curse words
caused the apocalypse You' think it
would have happened by now yeah if that
was the
case yeah and then Camp guy said I would
imagine the number of police reports and
crimes in Tokyo or Soul would be
magnitudes of numbers lower than what we
have here yeah now one thing they did
well lotuff here isn't even reported
well yeah that people don't bother
reporting [__] that yeah that too yeah
um one thing that they did bring up that
some of the law enforcement officers
brought up on the documentary about um
about you young CH was that um one thing
that they did do and they said they try
not to do this anymore because obviously
it's kind of R for abuse they're like
what they would try to do is if your
crimes were unsolved like they would
kind of like sweep it under the rug like
they wouldn't tell any because they
didn't want to look bad by saying it's
like hey we couldn't figure this one out
you know what I mean so it's like so
they would just kind of like you know if
it got solved of course they'd crow
about it everywhere because they wanted
to get promotions and all that but if
something was not solved then they would
just be
like they would just kind of like shoved
under the carpet I guess they would do
that kind of stuff so they so they did
admit that they were doing that kind of
stuff back then and let's see okay
yeah yeah Lim Lee said uh next time you
come uh a lot of things have changed
there oh I meant so yeah yeah yeah this
was uh 1990
1991 I was there when when um kimil song
died and we we thought the invasion
would happen when Kim song died but uh
Kim xong Kim xong Il took over and I
didn't know who he was later on I I was
able to do research to find out who Kim
Jong-il was and I kind of liked Kim
jongil he was crazy just a pot bellied
funny hair
making Godzilla movies with captured
Japanese film directors I wanted to just
show about that too he is like something
out of J it's crazy it's crazy it's a
crazy story yeah yeah and I saw a lot of
prop saw a lot of North Korean
propaganda films about Kim Jil about how
he could solve every [__] problem any
problem you could think of Kim jongo
could solve it he went to the power
stations and told everyone how to make
electricity he would go to all of the
music professors and tell them how to
make music he would go to the movie
studios and tell them how to make movies
he's doing all his an entire tour
through North Korea telling everybody
how to do their job and those those
videos are on YouTube beautiful beauti
this North Korean I canot patriotic
music Imagine yeah he go
that deep Kim Jong would go to a farm
and tell everybody how to grow potato
how to grow potatoes you know it's like
what the [__] did he think they were
doing prior to him getting there it's
like yeah bro been growing potatoes yeah
for like thousands of years thanks for
your input
though he goes to the pistol range and
he's shooting pistols but the thing is I
will tell you one thing Kim Jong ill
evidently he could shoot Kim Jong ill
ill could shoot there were Witnesses saw
him shoot says yeah he's good he's real
good but he he was good at one thing he
I think he was good at a lot of stuff no
I don't underestimate him I he was good
a lot of stuff because but he was like
you know the the Supreme one of the
Supreme leaders so he actually had some
experience in doing things and I think
he would go overseas sometimes that
shit's hilarious I think he was kind of
normal but he had well I mean it's kind
of not hilarious because it's also
terrifying yeah he had to put on a show
for the North Koreans because uh you
know I listen to a lot of North Korean
defectors their testimony and North
Korea is an alien planet it's
just yeah it's super weird weird it's a
cult basically well yeah it's like a
Countrywide cult but like I said it's
like most people there I'm sure that
they would [__] leave if they could
no no a lot of them won't they love it
they think it's the best place on the
planet and that they have a leader who's
taking care of them even though and and
sending all the bad people to work camps
and no they they they're totally
brainwashed totally brainwashed
they think it's great they think
starving is
great yeah
evidently Camp guy said this is in
reference to um giving up to ass for a
certain amount of money damn cam we have
to just keep bringing it we're not
picking on I mean you're the one that
said you're the one that pretty much
laid out exactly how much it would take
for it to happen you didn't have you
didn't have to do that you could have
like raised your I'd have been like
it'll take $1 million I'd have been like
that I'm not going to wh myself out just
for a car F you people no Camp guy said
there was a Stephen King short story
where a guy would get a huge payout all
he had to do was go to a children's
playground and Sucker Punch a little kid
one time
damn now see that's great that's a great
moral quander cuz would you do that it
would depend on the
kid I like can I pick the kid kid or
does it have to be just like a random
kid cuz I wouldn't go punch a random
like a nice kid but if he was an [__]
I think about it I would think about it
cuz some kids probably need a punch in
the face just saying no just kidding I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding yeah you
know what I mean but sort of but not all
right so uh Zach said I forget if I
brought it up already yeah I think you
did because I think I wrote it down um
but a show on the Lial space and back
rooms phenomenon would be super
fascinating I thought so too I think I
it down but I don't remember if I put it
in one of the polls yet but I will
because I kind of do want to do a show
about that and about that whole like
analog horror thing too that might be
fun but uh but yeah so let's start
talking about this [__] now even
though see I just did it again this
[__] so this guy here I don't
know I guess what they know about his uh
childhood or his past is from him cuz
he's like I said he's still alive he's
actually on death death row but as far
as I'm aware South Korea suspended the
death penal like it's still legal but
they just suspended it and I think it's
been suspended since
1997 so there's a bunch of prisoners on
death row but they're not doing the
execution so he's on death row but he's
still alive and I think he's only well
he's two years older than me cuz he was
born in 1970 so he's
53 53 years old so um so yeah so he grew
up in this family that was really really
poor which is important because it'll
kind of feed into his uh motives later
on probably like a real rural area now
not too long after he was born I think
his parents uh divorced or separated and
so him and his siblings they went to
live with their grandmother I think for
a few years and then their dad took them
back now because of his fam's
poverty um when he was at school he got
bullied a lot for being really poor now
they said and they actually kind of
talked about this slightly like on the
documentary too but they were saying
that he was actually like really um
talented as far as like creativity like
he could sing he could play guitar um he
could draw and actually if those were
his actual drawings that they showed on
the documentary pretty good yeah it's
like he looked almost like like a
professional cartoonist or something
like that basically basically he could
draw anime like Japanese anime he could
yeah yeah yeah like I said I'm not sure
because they didn't the weird thing
about it about the documentary was that
some of the stuff they showed like him
getting arrested and all the you know um
footage of that but it's like some of
the scenes that they had in between were
like reenactments obviously so um they
didn't really show him there's not
really a lot of pictures of him other
than the one that I used in the
thumbnail like that's him but most of
the other pictures are from his arrest
so he has like a mask over his face and
they call him the raincoat killer just
because he had that raincoat on in all
the famous pictures of him even though
it wasn't even his raincoat like they
gave him like the cops gave him a
raincoat because it was raining and then
the media picked up on it and started
calling him that so so it doesn't have
he wasn't wearing a rain coat when he
killed people or anything like that as
far as I know but that's just Why They
Call he just got that stereotyp he got a
stereotype yeah yeah yeah wearing that
when he saw him when yeah like when he
got arrested they put a a yellow
raincoat on him yeah somebody started
calling him that so so yeah so he was
actually like I said he got bullied a
lot but he was actually pretty talented
he was actually wanted to go to Art
School yeah but um couldn't get in
because one he had bad grades and two um
he was poor like they couldn't afford to
send him so he ended up going to
technical school but he quit and in his
teenage years decided to become a petty
criminal so there's that yeah another
thing that Jenny failed to mention is
that he's a good-looking guy yeah well
yeah like I said you can see the picture
on the yeah yeah he's he's a goodlooking
guy yeah he's not weird looking or
nothing which I would I would imagine
kind of like Ted
Bundy makes him more terrifying to women
because he he's able to deceive women
because he looks totally normal he's a
cute guy you'd go with him and then he'd
kill you if he was ugly or [__]
frightening looking you'd at least have
some kind of warning you go no I'm not
going with that dude yeah this dude uh
no I've seen photographs of him he
wouldn't women would he he was going
after professional girls they wouldn't
have any problem working with a guy like
that oh sure no
problem I did hear like in regards to
Ted Bundy though I did kind of hear that
a lot of women that met him or like
escaped that he didn't kill obviously
they said that yeah he was like okay
looking and stuff like that but that
they knew he was like a creep yeah as
soon as he started talking or like
interacting with them so it wasn't so he
couldn't pass for very long even though
he was like normal looking yeah like
people started getting alarm Bells like
as soon as he started like talking and
moving around been that way that's what
I'm when he was when he was talking to
the talking to the audience after he got
arrested yes see I'm not sure if that
was him or if that was just somebody
reading his I think it was I think it
was him uh of course I don't speak hungu
or I don't Korean I don't speak it but I
could tell he kind of had a halting
Cadence to his voice and he sounded a
little like he lacked a lot of
confidence so I have a feeling that when
you met him in real life he kind of had
that odd
presence about him that he that he was
hiding something yeah he was probably
like that and I think some women that
had interacted with him did think he was
a weirdo yeah yeah probably because to
do this kind of [__] you got to be you
got to be a weirdo I mean you can't this
is thinking isra like I said you can
maybe pass for normal for a little while
if you're really good at it but I think
most of the time like once you get in a
situation where they're like actually
talking and interacting with you I think
most people uh with any kind of survival
Instinct at all be like yeah this mother
this is a bad person yeah well they even
said I don't know like a couple of the
um the detectives that were working on
the case they said when they brought the
dude in cuz at first this is kind of
unclear but at first when they brought
him in they weren't sure that he was the
murderer they picked him up for like
something else kind of or kind of a
lesser charge which I'll get into in a
bit but um but a couple of them said
that as soon as they looked at him like
looked in his eyes they thought there is
something wrong with that dude like they
knew that there was something the other
ones thought that he was too [__] to do
that that he was that was yeah that was
another thing too so he was kind of yeah
it's like oh there's no way that that
dude's the killer like he was too but
that was that was rookie policemen yeah
like the older ones were kind of like oh
I'm pretty sure that that dude did
something bad yeah the uh serial killers
typically kind of H well you know kind
of some lot they are
[__] yeah a lot of them yeah cuz why
are they so threatened by woman you know
what I mean they're they a lot of them
are killing women because they're
jealous of women when you actually read
between the lines of what they're doing
so you have a person that doesn't have a
very good uh
self-confidence person with a bad
self-image and then you know and they
just get these really warped ideas of
how [__] works and right I mean that's
for sure what this dude had right like
those dudes go after prostitutes because
if they were women they'd be doing that
they're that kind of you know they're
like well and plus it must be said that
sex workers are easier targets because
go cuz they'll go with you CU because
you're paying them yeah it's like a low
it's a lwh hanging fruit easy it didn't
start that way well yeah and like I said
and and there's kind of the added bonus
that when they disappear like they don't
like maybe the cops don't look for them
as hard to you see sex to a man is
something that he's kind of biologically
programmed to want that that's something
good like a steak it's but for men yeah
like Ste SE is like a steak like a steak
or it's a reward or like a car or it's
like something that you can give to a
guy he and he's like wow this is this is
some cool [__] okay this is some cool
[__] yeah it doesn't come easy he's got
to do [__] to get it he's got to be
successful or good-looking or charming
or he has to pay for it it's not
something that comes free all right so
to him it has
value
okay those dudes couldn't go out and
sell Dick it doesn't work that way women
are don't have those Dy the same Drive
well then why would we pay for it they
like why would a woman pay for it so
they get jealous of that they see that
as women having power over them like man
they're more powerful than me they can
sell themselves that they're more
valuable than me
I couldn't sell this I can't give this
away I got to work to get it so that
that's where the jealousy starts yeah
that's what I was saying if that was if
that if that dude could sell Dick he'd
be out there selling dick although this
kind of goes back to what we were saying
before about people talking about sex
work being like an easy way to make
money it absolutely is not but a lot of
people do kind of see it that way it's
like oh you know but it's it's not easy
no it still work no if it worked for men
the way it would work for women the guy
would think it was easy goes man I got
to sit around and just [__] these hot
chicks well yeah that's the way he would
see it and yeah there's going to be some
ugly chicks but I'll [__] them too I'm
GNA make money so actually no that's
that's a that's a that's a man's
conception of Heaven yeah they're
imagining it from their perspective
they're not able to imagine it from the
woman's perspective where I got to let
this scumbag in here inside me to do his
thing and I don't really like this dude
you know stinks they don't see that
smacks me around and all other kind of
stuff right right it's like which is not
F this dude is strong enough to kill me
with his bare hands you know what I mean
yeah like that's another thing you don't
yeah so they don't really well that's
they can't you have to understand why
would a serial killer see it from a
woman's point of view he can't obviously
he can't well a lot of just regular
things from his point of view a lot of
regular dudes can't see things from one
point of view there is even worse wor
because he doesn't even see other people
is people okay so everything is just him
everybody else is a non-player
character like they're they're they're
like robots that's he sees other
people's robots yeah but in reality he's
a robot there's nothing to those guys
yeah well yeah that's a good way of
putting it they they really do seem to
see other people as just like objects
well that's cuz that's that's what they
are they're like lizards they're either
obstacles or they're things to be used
for their own right edification I don't
think serial killers have true
Consciousness I think they're more like
a robot there's said and I'm sure
there's a spectrum there but um yeah I I
don't think I'm going to argue too much
with you on that it's like a weird form
of
autism but but not because most I mean
most people with Autism don't it's not
really exactly the same said it's like a
weird form yeah I don't think they have
Consciousness because they can't feel
empathy I think that's the issue right I
think that's the issue they see other
people as just some as a as a non-living
character in their movie yeah watch
that's just the thing so I can do
whatever I want to that
so they only see other people through
their point of view so he sees those
women from his point of view and he sees
these prostitutes is they got it made
man and they got more power than me so
he's going to kill him gonna punish him
for that yeah that's what they do well
he even used that word punish he wanted
to punish
them but yeah so he didn't start out
like that though which like I said maybe
and I I and I hesitate to say that's why
it took so long to catch him because it
didn't really I mean in The Grand scheme
of things when we're talking about
serial killers sometimes especially the
ones from the quote unquote Heyday from
like the' 60s and 70s sometimes it took
them like 10 20 30 years to catch the
[__] right look at like BTK and
[__] like that this dude it was less
than a year but he did kind of like a
spree more than a it wasn't like a
decades long you know kind of marathon
it was more like a Sprint let's put it
that way Miss Lee is saying that he
picked the process because of their jobs
yeah cuz they weren't important and no
one cared yeah and they said that on the
documentary as well that's part of it
yeah that's part of it one of the main
things is that he picked those because
they were available yeah he could just
call them and they would come to his
house easy to it's easy to get them to
come to your house so that was probably
the most important thing he didn't like
he liked he did he disliked all women he
just made an excuse oh well they're
[__] so I could kill them now he would
have done that to anybody because he was
killing old ladies he started off
killing old ladies and just just regular
hous so it didn't start off sex families
actually what it is is that break the
breaking into people's houses and
killing whole families is too difficult
it's too risky so he went to an easier
Target which is prostitutes you could
call them and nobody's keeping track of
where they are so you could kill one and
they couldn't prove that that girl was
with you cuz you don't know who that she
was with and who whoever runs those
brothel in Korea they didn't know how to
do it right you got to know you got to
know the customer that she's going to
and what his name is and his address
well I will note that how he got caught
was because one of the brothel owners
got suspicious yeah and called the cops
we'll get into that too right so at
least one of them yeah did like Crack
the Case to be honest yeah because of
that but I I have noticed Jenny and I
have covered Miss Lee Miss Lee Jenny and
I have covered many of these cases on
the the show and I've read a lot of FBI
profiling books about serial killers
over the years there's always an element
of jealousy there's an element that
these guys are jealous of women they see
women is more powerful than them so this
is striking back at women in their minds
because their view of the world is very
Twisted okay they can only see the thing
see things from their point of view they
can't see it through the women's point
of
view yeah what like just like there was
one that just happened a while back just
got caught he was a big ugly dude he
killed little bitty cute prostitutes
that's exactly because he could never be
little and cute that was part of it who
you talking about Lisk Lis Long Island
Lisk yeah Lisk yeah long yeah he could
never be those girls ever so it's an
element of underlying
jealousy yeah it's [__] up it's yeah
he was jealous of their beauty and their
cuteness
and like you said he was just kind of
like well it's they just make this money
doing that and it's and there's some
kind of weird like yeah they're taking
advantage of men yeah that that's way
but then they still want to [__] them
though yeah you know yeah and then they
hate themselves for it yeah yeah it's
messed up yeah their psychology is
messed up Danny ring asked what we were
drinking uh screwdrivers we're actually
both have screwdrivers today VOD orange
juice yeah it's pretty good actually
we're not out of orange juice had AR no
I got orange juice okay that's good cuz
I was like I put I made the drink
earlier and I was just kind of like I
got lemonade in there too oh that's
right I spiked it with both to make it
go the Oh okay that's aidea running out
so oh well we can do that next time it's
good and I think we also have some
orange crush or fruit punch or something
but yeah so um so yeah where was I okay
so when he was a teenager like I said he
dropped out of school and he basically
just went into a life of crime uh now at
first he started out with fairly petty
crime he also it seemed like when he was
a teenager kind of established this um
hostility toward the rich as he felt
like they were kind of keeping him down
you know what I mean like I guess there
was like a wealthy family that lived
nearby that he would see and he just
they had all this stuff and he didn't
have anything so he got kind of
resentful about it now in
1988 and again in
1991 um he was convicted of theft
and then uh
1993 I believe it was he was um arrested
again for
burglary now right around this time in
uh June of 1993 he actually got married
and the woman that he married uh who's
well I've only ever seen her called uh
Miz
hang she was also a masseuse so I'm
assuming that means sex worker right in
that context I don't know um well I
think that the way they kind of
described it later on was was yeah she
did that rub and tug like she worked at
a massage parlor and was like an escort
you know what I mean so he married her
now they had a son together in October
of
1994 so he did have a son uh he was
married and had a kid four years after
the son was born in
1998 he was actually sentenced to
another 2 years years in prison and this
time it was for theft forgery and I
think like identity theft so at first
started out just kind of I mean crimes
still but like kind of [__] crimes
you know what I mean but then uh so he
served I believe the whole sentence for
that so he gets let
out um and pretty much as soon as he got
LED out of prison on the identity theft
charge he gets arrested again for for
raping a 15-year-old
girl so this [__] is just
incorrigible like he started young and
I'm not really sure if he could have
been helped at any point so for the rape
he only got 3 years 6 months which
seems um insufficient I'm going to say
especially considering what he went on
to do but you know hindsight's 2020 I'm
just saying 3 years and 6 months for
raping a teenager that seems a little
bit not a lot I'm just
saying so he went to prison for that now
while he was in prison his wife
understandably divorced him that was in
2000 now apparently while he was in jail
Tom wasn't here when I said he was
actually convicted of uh raping a
15-year-old girl okay yeah they didn't
even talk about that on the they didn't
mention a lot of his cuz like I said he
had a a pretty long criminal history is
stretching back to when he was a
teenager like I said he started out with
kind of petty [__] robbery identity
theft that kind of stuff but um he did
actually get um as soon as he was let
out of prison in 2000 um he basically
raped a girl and went back to prison but
he was only sentenced for three or six
months which like I said for rape seems
not much Miss Lee's throwing in all
kinds of stuff in Miss Lee said the pimp
didn't know what did he say she said
know where she went but just thought he
was just a customer yeah because he had
called there before he had called there
well that's how he recognized which like
I said we'll get into it but that's how
he recognized the phone number so when
the when when the pimp called the
customer the serial killer did he say
where's the girl he said what she left
no the no what happened was at least
according to the documentary and what I
the [__] that I read what happened was
was that uh Yu young CH who is
apparently not the sharpest tool in in
the shed he called the massage parlor
and I guess he had called that massage
parlor before like to order girls before
to order
girls but he used one of his one of the
disappear girls phones like a dumbass
yeah which duh watchs like that is a
rookie mistake just saying but he so he
used one of the girls phones and the guy
that ran the massage parlor recognized
the phone number as hers and he's like
man that girl's been that girl's missing
yeah but why didn't he know that she was
missing back then and go hey I don't
know how long I don't know what the time
period was like in between if you got a
girl you send her to a customer you know
the address of the customer you should
know the name you should have his
identification I mean you that's how you
do it today yeah I don't know how it
worked back then like maybe they were a
little bit more LAX or they just thought
ah she just wandered off or whatever
happens all maybe there was a high
turnover this is how they do it
online in an independent worker an
independent provider okay this is going
an yeah like an escort or whatever she
if you contact her she will say we let
me talk to you on Skype yeah look and
she's talking you on Skype face to face
and she says can I see your ID and you
take your ID and you put it at the
camera she takes a screenshot of your
ID and then she says I got a shot of
your ID I'm going to go ahead and work
with you but just let just just so you
know you know I have somebody who keeps
an eye out me if I don't come back
they're going to be come look for you
yeah well you got to do that out you
don't want anything to do with that he's
like oh no problem then okay he's a good
customer yeah so that's how they you got
to see that dude's ID and if that was me
I would send that picture to like every
[__] I knew before girl boyfriend the
boyfriend's got the idea know he's like
yeah okay this is where I'm going that's
where I'm going okay and I'll be back
this and that I'll send you text when
I'm done and you know when I get there
and when I'm done so they know I mean
it's a very dangerous profession you got
to cover your [__] times boyfriend
drives are there you got to cover your
[__] ass yeah well if it was like
like I said I would never do this in a
million years cuz no thank you but um
yeah I I mean I would have somebody
drive me there and wait for me they do
usually yeah they all have drivers yeah
the driver's like a bouncer a lot of
times it's the
boyfriend yeah he'll be out in the damn
parking lot waiting for you know in the
driveway waiting for an hour like I said
understandable you don't know who the
[__] that dude is yeah well you know
that settles every that takes all the
danger away right I mean I'm not saying
you couldn't still get get murdered cuz
you could but it makes it like a lot
less get killed cuz D going going to
kill you come got to cover around honest
to be honest the the sad thing is that I
read enough True Crime to know that even
if you're not an escort even if you're
just going on a date with somebody you
met on you know online like Plenty of
Fish or if that's even still around or
match or whatever the one that they're
doing now is um you got to like you got
to tell all your friends hey this is him
send the picture send the add this is
where I'm going this is the restaurant
we're going and it's like you know I
I'll send you a text if I got to escape
and all this other kind of [__] you got
to do all that stuff cuz you don't know
who that [__] is he's a
stranger nowadays the hookers are
working off the trist do link and
[__] it's it's set up they got that
[__] system it's where a girl who
could be an independent provider can
safely contact these guys and if he
kills her he's not getting away she's
got all his Goods on him but the thing
is is that he he knows that she does
yeah and they don't want this one time
things they want regular a regular
customer that they can see every couple
months they want like 30 of them that's
what I mean but like I said you really
got to watch your ass and not just if
you're an escort like just if you're
going on a regular date with somebody
you met well [__] I mean that's not it's
not just online it's like [__] you could
meet somebody at a club or in a grocery
store or something like that and like be
like hey let's go out on a date or
something like that they might be a Sero
killer you don't know so it's just kind
of like you really got to yeah tell
everybody where you're going Miss Lee is
explaining how it worked in Korea at
that time yeah that they just know the
phone number they don't know the place
yeah cuz he recognized the phone number
which I thought was interesting yeah he
recognized the phone number he's like oh
that's one of the girls phones that's a
very low Tech way of doing it and that
was
2003 they had the technology where you
should know the address and that dy's
name and a photograph of them you could
have they could have taken a screenshot
in 2003 couldn't they oh I don't know no
I don't think so that was 20 years ago
yeah I don't think you could take us St
they didn't have smartphones back then
yeah that's right smartphones now
they're going to want a screenshot of
your [__] ID if you're not
comfortable giving the ID you're not
getting the service cuz [__] even when
me and you first started going out which
was 2010 2011 you still had a flip phone
that didn't have a it had like a camera
on it but like a really really shitty
camera real low resolution like really
really low resolution and there was a
damn built-in two-way radio in that yeah
you could use it as a walkie talk and
that was 2010 2011 so in 2003 yeah I
don't think heavy duty motor roll the
phone waterproof and [__] it was like
something from [__]
combat but that's all obsolete now well
yeah yeah Lim Lee said they do wait
outside but usually women call the pimp
or drive uh to come pick her up okay
yeah like I said you got to [__]
watch your ass especially that's a it's
a very very dangerous profession I'm
just saying and that's not the only
reason I wouldn't do it but it's like
that's one of the reasons for sure miss
Lee I just I would go to DN
Ewan just to the nightclubs and it was
just a nightclub with an apartment out
in the back and she'd take you to your
room it was like Chinese like Korean
Disneyland dragons and [__] black and
red rooms with gold and lights and [__]
it didn't have a
brothel feel to it it was more like a
nightclub
feel they were cute man real cute nice
girls yeah Tom was over there in the
Army and he was single then so yeah I
could do whatever I wanted so he could
just do whatever he wanted and he did
everybody else do everybody else is
doing whatever they wanted everybody
else is doing whatever they wanted I was
having fun
yeah once a month yeah it was like
getting out of
prison that's really funny cuz it was
like being in prison really yeah I gu
worse sleeping outside yeah especially
during the
winter um okay so yeah so he gets out of
prison in 19 uh in 2000 rather and
immediately rapes girl and goes back to
prison until 2003 I think he got out uh
his wife divorced him understandably
while he was in prison for rape now
while he's in jail apparently this whole
philosophy that he had about um rich
people uh you know being the cause of
all his problems and women being the
cause of all his problems and that
seemed to kind of exacerbate uh when he
was in prison he also started admiring
other career Korean serial killers uh
particularly one named Jong du Yong
hopefully I'm pronouncing some of these
kind of correctly if I'm not I apologize
um that guy also targeted rich people so
he thought that was kind of like a good
idea so he's like maybe I should do the
same thing now as we mentioned
earlier this guy and this is pretty
common uh among a certain type of serial
killer they think they're smarter than
everyone else um he claimed to have an
IQ of 140 which is pretty high if you
don't know and um you know he he was
real into to and they we'll kind of go
into this later too but he was real into
kind of like faking sickness like to
escape and [__] like that to like to get
the cops to let their guard down and
stuff like and he would do that at some
point too but yeah he thought he was
smarter than everybody he would call the
cops morons when he got caught and [__]
I don't doubt he was one 40 he probably
was yeah there's lots of those there
yeah there are it just he just happened
to have a bunch of mental problems uh
yeah that's putting it
mildly I don't know he did some dumb
[__] though I'm I'm going to say well he
was a rookie criminal yeah that's true
he doesn't know police investigative
technique well see I think that's
another thing that handicaps them is
that they think they're smarter than the
cops and it's like they think they can
figure all this stuff out and the cops
won't also figure that out because they
think the cops are way dumber than them
but they're they think they can figure
out the way cops operate without any
training yeah that you have to
understand how cops are trained and and
they're investigative
techniques which I did that I did PBI
post blast in investigation how to train
cops how to put bombs back together and
figure out who made them worked for a
company that did
that you must know how police are
trained if you want to fool them because
you have to foil investigative
techniques if you can foil the
investigative techniques that they use
you can avoid
indictment if you can't be indicted you
can never be convicted and it's not
doesn't matter what they suspect it just
matters what they can
prove but this dude right here here
[__] he straight up confessed he you
know so he seemed wanted to get caught
he seemed like the kind of person that
wanted to boast about it yeah like I
think that he thought yeah that he was
um yeah he was just one of those ones
that wanted to brag like he thought
everyone was going to be like oo aren't
you cool or aren't you amazing or
something like that it just seemed like
he he came across like that to me I
guess yeah he just thought he was the
[__] and that he could fool trained
policemen yeah without having any
training of his own on how they you must
just like any any battle philosophy you
must know the enemy and the ways of the
enemy before you can fight them so he
made a mistake there he was so arrogant
he thought he could go up against the
police without knowing anything and that
they wouldn't like figure it out yeah
and like I said yeah like the cops got a
lot of flak for how quote unquote long
it took to and he did murder a lot of
people in this you know 10mon period
that he was active but I mean 10 months
in serial killer terms that's not bad
like I said we've had serial killers
over here that it took them like decades
to [__]
catch so I'm not going to [__] on them
too hard yeah there's like different
situations where that was going on some
of those dudes were maybe like truckers
and they were just killing runaways and
stuff like that so nobody thought to
link the [__] up or anything like that
but they know that see that's why they
target those kind of people so I'm just
going to say that you know 10 months
yeah 10 months is a long time to catch
somebody that doing spree killings like
this especially as egregious as the ones
that he did but it's not that long in
serial killer terms so I'm not going to
[__] on the cops too hard like the
Korean cops they they really did seem to
be trying working hard but they had a
lot
of departmental issues going on too
which we'll get into thank you very much
Bryce that is very very nice of you
instead of people thinking he was
amazing everyone just thinks he was a
creepy jerk yeah that's usually the case
um but uh these types of dudes they're
like so delusional
I guess they're Legends in their own
mind you know what I mean yeah he's
trying to build something that he
appreciates and you don't you know what
I mean he's like building a damn model
or something but it's it's it's his
supposed Legend he loves it yeah
everybody else is like yeah you you kind
of suck dude yeah that's another thing
that's like it's very very weird to me I
think we talked about this I mean we've
talked about this on a lot of shows
because a lot of serial killers have
this really warped they they think
they're doing this like this big Amazing
Project and like that everyone's going
to like see it and like be impressed or
awed or something and I'm just kind of
like how [__] how like not on this
planet are you right now you know what I
mean because it's like nobody else
thinks like that but I guess like you
said they're so narcissistic they're so
self-absorbed that they think everybody
thinks as [__] up as they do but they
don't uh Miss Lee said something about
he got caught anyway he got caught got a
long time in jail usually not that long
America may not understand it something
like that here yeah I mean well he did
get the death penalty so they just
haven't which that's the same thing that
happens here they give you the death
penalty and they usually die in prison
before they execute a long time for him
to because you have so many like um
appeals no we understand how it could
happen in Korea because uh Korea is just
another country in the world it's small
and the thing is is that America is a
bunch of small little areas just because
it happens in the United States doesn't
mean it happened in Florida it's like 50
countries combined and if you kind of
break them up they're kind of rare in
any one place it's just chances are it's
eventually going to happen in a place
like Korea uh I mean I'm not saying that
the what I was going to say it tends to
be in places that are almost kind of
like Po
industrial uh there's certain places
where it happens and Korea got to the
level of development where you had a
dude who had weird kind of class
Envy hatred towards women um he lived
lifestyle where he had the ability to do
it and the means to do it he was doing
it now Jenny went on to talk about how
poor he was he wasn't that poor he was
nowhere near as poor as somebody in
India okay in the poor neighborhoods of
India I mean I saw I saw Korea in no way
would I call that a poor country it was
[__] tight it was it was nice the
poorest neighborhoods in Korea could
never compare with the poorest
neighborhoods in the United States
poorest neighborhoods in the United
States be much
worse so he was just poor in comparison
to the PE his peers which is probably
the only experience he had so to him it
would seem like yeah he was on the
bottom of the token because in that
Society you would be yeah you can think
to yourself yeah if I lived in another
country it'd be like a 100 times worse
but that doesn't yeah you no Korea had a
good standard of living yeah but yeah
that's the thing I you know I I don't I
was going to say something but I don't
remember what it was but um but yeah so
let's see where I at okay so here's the
thing so he gets out of prison in 2003
what this Lee has to go bye me bye Miss
Lee bye thank you for dropping by yeah
you can listen later yeah you can listen
to the rest of it later yeah so he gets
out of prison on the rape charge in
2003 less than two weeks later after he
gets out of prison he starts his Killing
Spree now as I said it didn't start with
the sex workers that was later so for a
while they thought it was like two
different
Killers so the first crime took place on
September 24th
2003 so this guy he like his hero who's
another serial killer he wanted to kill
rich people so he decides he's going to
go to like wealthy neighborhoods and
like break into people's houses and just
[__] them up that's what he did so the
first one that he did he goes to this
neighborhood um CAD dong
and he breaks into a house which is
owned by a 72-year-old man who was a un
uh retired University professor and his
uh wife who was
68 now he comes at both of them with a
hammer and beat them both to death uh I
believe that the um Professor his name
was uh Le diaku he was actually stabbed
in the neck prior to being beaten to
death but he beat them to death with a
hammer I just left him in the house yeah
and what's odd about it is it wasn't a
normal hammer it took him a long time to
figure out what the murder weapon was a
long
time they were trying to match it up it
was something like a hammer but it
wasn't like any Hammer that they that
they had
tested turns out what it was is it was a
sledgehammer but he cut down and made a
custom handle for it so it was small a
very heavy sled so it it's was like a
sledgehammer head but with like with a
small small H hand it was his secret
weapon you'd carry it around bow he hit
somebody full force with it to kill him
in a single blow usually yeah because
they said when they got to the crime
scene it's like the dents in the heads
yeah were like they they hadn't really
seen anything like that and they and
they're like they had all this that like
well is it a regular Hammer is it a bat
like they couldn't figure out what it
was cuz it was like a weird shape but it
took them a while to like figure out
what it was so yeah so that was the
first one that he did the next one took
place on October 9th and he actually
killed three people uh three members of
the same family and this one was um one
of them was
85 uh this one was 85 her name was uh
Kang
yunon and she was also budgeon to death
with a hammer her daughter-in-law whose
name was Lee Suk Jin who was 60 years
old uh was also killed and her
handicapped grandson uh go Jin Su who
was 35 uh they were all beaten to death
in the same house this was in a a
different neighborhood but also kind of
an affluent
neighborhood now only a few days later
like only a week later October 16th he
attacked again uh in a slightly
different neighborhood it was all kind
of in the same area but in slightly
different neighborhoods this was a
60-year-old woman uh named junhe Yu Juni
and she was also beaten to death with a
hammer um now she was actually found
alive by her son but um died a half hour
later from her
injuries then on November
18th uh he broke into a house and killed
uh Kim jongok who was 87 and the
housekeeper whose name was uh be high
who was 53 years old at this particular
crime scene he accidentally cut himself
while uh attempting to break into a safe
I should note that the crimes prior to
this the police were completely baffled
because nothing of value was taken from
any of the houses so you know at first
they're like oh it was a robbery gone
wrong but nothing was stolen so they
were just kind of like what the [__] was
the motive then like they had never seen
this before yeah in the military you'd
call that a raid you just go in there
and you kill a bunch of people and then
get the [__] out before retaliation hits
that's that's all is a RAID so that
means the the the motive was the people
yeah yeah he just wanted to kill the
people
yeah which is weird because I was kind
of thinking I know this is kind of
[__] up but like when I was watching
the documentary I was like if he was so
upset about being poor it's like if
you're going to go to that extent you're
going to like break into some quote
unquote like affluent people's houses
and beat them to death with a hammer
it's like you might as well take their
[__] right but he never did so I guess I
don't know if he was trying to make a
statement
or he thought that would be easier for
him to get caught or what I I kind of
suspect the
former um because maybe he thought oh
well if I steal their stuff then it'll
just look like a robbery like they'll
like the motive will be clear and that's
not what I want to get across I don't
know he kind of seemed like that to me
but he didn't take anything so they so
the cops thought that was really weird
because they're so at first they were
just kind of like um when the first
couple crimes happened they were like
this is H this has to be somebody with
like a grudge against this family or
something because why would somebody
just come and do this and not take
anything you know what I mean like there
seems no reason so but you know they
investigated and they couldn't find
anybody that had any motive to kill any
of them so it was very confusing to them
however at this particular scene he did
actually try to break into a safe in the
house he didn't get in um but he
apparently cut his hand while he was
breaking into the safe and got some uh
you know Blood on the safe or whatever
cuz he cut his hand so at this point he
at least had the wherewithal I guess to
it's like well I need to destroy the
evidence cuz this is going to you know
leave DNA or whatever so he tried to
burn the house down um he didn't
entirely succeed he did burn quite a bit
of it and I think he did succeed in
burning the DNA evidence because it
wasn't burned completely down CU I saw
the photos that were in the documentary
but he did like kind of burn that area
down but he did try to burn it down so
as I said at this stage cops had never
seen anything like this before they
couldn't figure out what the dude was
doing um and they didn't really want to
at first it seems and some of them
admitted this they didn't really want to
tell the public that it was a serial
killer I guess not only because they
didn't want to panic them but because
they didn't want it to look like they
didn't know what they were doing or they
were out of their depth you know what I
mean yeah well that's something I
noticed it's a good time to talk about
in all the Eastern countries China Japan
Korea countries like that there's a big
thing about s the government Saving Face
they must seem to be in total control
they have to have almost like a Godlike
reputation you're not supposed to be
questioning the government they're all
knowing all powerful okay they know
what's right and you're just a citizen
it's very paternalistic but that goes in
line with Eastern cultures uh very uh
paternal hierarchy type stuff stuff so
they can never show
weakness never if they let's say they
convicted the wrong man all right of a
crime it's gonna they're not going to
want to reverse that you could show them
over and over again that that dude was
innocent and if they release him they'll
have egg on their face that's how strong
it can get I mean they kind of do that
here but like we're not to the extent
we'll look bad if we do that right you
know like we'll look like we didn't know
we were and I I do kind of feel like and
to their credit at least the officers
that talked on the documentary they did
seem aware of this um because they said
because I guess things have changed
since then like since because this was
20 years ago that this was going on but
they did seem to be like yeah well it it
did seem like image was Paramount um if
you didn't know what was going on and
they didn't clearly uh with this
situation then you either had to they
they tried to like play it off at the
beginning like oh this is somebody that
knew them or that had a grudge against
them or they're not connected or
something like that they didn't want to
come out and say this is a serial killer
and we don't know who it is or why
they're doing it because it would make
them look bad like it would make them
look incompetent yeah and they really
didn't want that yeah so there yeah so
there was like a lot of that going on
and like I said to their credit they did
really seem to realize that cuz they did
kind of talk pretty openly about it on
the
documentary um but you know they they
said the you know the silver lining of
this case was that it caused a lot of uh
Improvement change yeah um you know yeah
I mean Korea likes to be a traditional
Society but you got to change [__] when
you're wrong you got to keep you got to
keep improving your game and they they
did yeah yeah you don't I mean it took
this but because they did get their [__]
together if being traditional means
you're [__] over the innocent [__]
people over no you got you got to change
that yeah you got you got to fix that
[__] you got to fix that [__] and you
can't just go around like smoothing
everything over when there's something
bad going on that everybody needs to
know about so they didn't really and it
seems in this point too that the
media kind of scooped them on this
because the media were already talking
about this is probably a serial killer
and like so they were already going on
the news saying this is probably a
serial killer but the cops are saying
that it's not so you know what I mean so
they were kind of getting undermined a
little bit by the me but you know
rightfully so and in this case because
it was a serial killer as it happened
but they were reporting that but the
cops didn't want to say that so um okay
so at this point they didn't really have
a lot of evidence really the only
physical evidence they had was um they
had some Sho prints like they knew the
cops knew from pretty early on that at
least three of these crimes were
connected because they found like the
same um shoe print like at three of the
scenes like one of them and they weren't
great ones either they but I mean they
were just kind of partial like one was
inside the house one was on um like an
air conditioning unit outside and it was
real faint they assumed that he had
climbed on that to like look into the
house or climb in a window or something
like that but I think it was was it
three of the scenes or four of the
scenes of the murders that had like the
same uh shoe print yeah I think it was
only two no I'm pretty sure it was at
least three it might have been four
remember them superimposing two the
footprints yeah but that was like first
and then they had like another one yeah
I'm pretty sure it was at least three
maybe four wore the same damn shoes yeah
there she called themal she called them
Buffalo shoes it must be a brand yeah
I'm thinking that's a brand of shoes
like which I don't maybe we have them
here on Miss Lee she left so she
wouldn't know yeah but she's gone yeah
cuz I never heard of those maybe we have
them here I don't I'm not real up on
like [__] shoe brands probably like a
Korean version of Buster Brown I saw
them they were just leather shoes with
rubber Souls yeah work shoe looking
thing so they knew that it was probably
the same dude but it's just kind of like
really the only other evidence they had
was they had um they said this was 2003
so there wasn't like CCTV cameras
everywhere in Korea back then however it
so happened that a house or a business
or something that was really close to
the house where the murder happened had
a whole bunch of I guess it was an
office because they said they had a
whole bunch of um cameras outside that
were monitoring the employees as they
were coming and
going now these cameras one of the
cameras picked
up a man walking down the street at
right around the time of the murder
either just before or just after and
they're assuming that this is the killer
because no one else was around at the
time and then when they showed the
footage to the victim's families uh one
of them said that's my dad's I guess it
was my dad's jacket so it was one of the
victim's jacket that the guy was wearing
now you couldn't see his face you could
only see his back and he was just like
walking so they weren't really sure what
to do they're like should we release
this to the public if we do that then
we're going to tip the killer off that
we know something about him um and that
might make him bolt yeah and we're not
going to be able to catch him but on the
other hand this is kind of the only lead
that we have maybe someone will
recognize the way he walks or his hair
or something you know what I mean even
though it's you could just see his back
so it wasn't really yeah he took that
jacket he must be he must have taken
that to cover up blood he probably got
blood on his shirt maybe yeah maybe he
was coming from the murder at that point
Yeah well yeah cuz he had the guy's
jacket he had one of the victim's jacket
so he was coming from there there been
hiding the fact that he got blood on
himself and he didn't want maybe had to
take public transportation didn't want
people to see the blood yeah because he
was pretty good about not leaving behind
much evidence and not taking anything
with him right so that must have been
kind of a last resort thing
um DVD Dragon said yeah like confusion
that what Confucian values he's talking
about them not not want to admit that
they're wrong about something the
authorities uh no uh Koreans or
Christians I think Presbyterian mostly
uh but they there is just that theme in
eastern
culture is that uh the authorities are
not supposed to be wrong if they're
wrong then the harmony uh Harmony is
upset you you can't can't trust
Authority they're very authoritarian
even if
they're good well intended they're still
authoritarian it's just the the tone of
that Society um not saying it's a bad
thing because they do a lot of things
right um but they don't like to admit
that they're wrong which I to me that
seems like a
weakness yeah well they eventually end
up admitting that they're wrong when
they are but they don't want admit
they're wrong cuz they're afraid that
they're going to disturb their Authority
and that there won't be no one will
believe in them and then the harmony
will be shattered and will be at the end
each other's throats and lions and dogs
and cats sleeping together it'll be
chaos you know like just like
some what was that from [__]
Ghostbusters yeah Mass hysteria yeah
Mass hysteria yeah that that's what
they're doging cats living they want to
have a peaceful and tranquil appearance
to
everything where sometimes the world
it's not like that but I do well like I
said it does kind of work to an extent
cuz it is you know compared to they are
very peaceful yeah yeah so so it does
work they have internal piece not so
much external the Japanese the Chinese
and the Koreans we've been fighting each
other for thousands of years but they
keep it all in the town well recently
recently it's they haven't been doing
anything but for thousands of years they
fought each other yeah maybe they got it
all out of their systems no they still
they still have all kinds of resentment
that the chines hate the Japanese I'm
just making a joke but like I said I
don't know like what really is better to
just kind of like have all these
resentments and bury them or to just
kind of like get them out in the open
the Chinese don't forget anything I
guess there's kind of like there's pros
and cons to both approaches I'm not
saying either one is completely right or
completely wrong out of all of them I
like the Koreans it's probably pretty
it's probably the best to do like a
combo I like the Koreans best out of all
of them um followed by the Japanese but
I think the Japanese are kind of a
little too uptight and everything has to
be their way they don't they don't you
know like if you live in Japan it can
drive you crazy if you're a Westerner
because they they'll complain about you
wearing cologne and that you got to they
they believe in total
Conformity if you got a daughter in
school there and she's in Japanese
school and her hair is blonde they're
going to ask her to Dy it black because
all children have black hair they're
really that [__] weird about it weird
okay
well children are supposed to have black
hair yeah but she's
blonde oh well but she has to dyet Black
so they're all the same
yeah which okay mhm but yeah so um so it
seemed like the cops went through a big
uh a lot of soul searching over whether
they should release this CCTV footage to
the media or not um initially it seemed
like they were leaning to where we don't
really want to because it might spook it
him and you know then we might he might
run off and we'll never catch him but I
guess the ones that wanted to release it
won out in the end because they did
release it and it was all over the place
like they put it all over the news
nationally so it may have been that the
ubiquity of this
footage probably was a major factor in
contributing to the nearly thre Monon
gap between uh his first series of
crimes the rich people murders if you
want to call him that and his second
series which was the quote unquote sex
worker murders because there was a
almost a three Monon three Monon Gap in
between those and that happened right
after that uh footage was released like
I said you couldn't recognize him it
could have been pretty much anybody but
you know like I said they knew it was
the killer because one of the um
victim's families like recognized the
jacket that he was wearing as one of the
victim's jackets so they figured that it
was probably him and I guess because of
the time and everything so yeah so
there's a 3-month gap where nothing
happened and they're just kind of like
well what happened to him like did he
move away did he die or what's going on
with
that now apparently they find out later
um in December of 2003 December
11th uh Yu young Cho had actually met a
new girlfriend now this girlfriend was
also an escort which this is kind of
explaining a lot but when she found out
that he had a criminal
history and told him to go pound sand he
decided I'm just going to kill all these
[__] apparently so he got rejected by
an escort yeah and so he got bitter yeah
now I will note that he um hated women
before this he had actually hated his
ex-wife cuz she divorced him when he was
in prison for the rape charge which can
you imagine like that [__] prison for
raping a 15-year-old girl and that [__]
divorced me yeah so unreasonable he
probably said it didn't happen probably
or she wanted it she she didn't that's
what they always say it didn't happen
and that [__] didn't believe me yeah it
was probably yeah it's probably these
[__] blah blah blah yeah these
[__] are the same it's the same song
of dance with these kind of
[__] to be honest with you it's
like you can [__] predict it just you
know like you can predict the tides he's
got a screw loose big time yeah so yeah
so but yeah and he was actually he later
admitted that he was actually going to
kill his
exwife uh when that whole thing happened
like when she divorced him
earlier they didn't cover this in the
[__] yeah they didn't talk a lot
about this well they didn't talk a lot
about his past or his prior criminal
record I kind of the the documentary was
more about the investigation it was more
focused on the law enfor like how they
caught him you know I yeah it's on
Netflix it's a great it's a great show
you all should watch it it's it's in
hungo but it's got good subtitles and it
shows Korea it shows it shows hooker
Hill you'll see it yeah in there I'm
like oh I remember that place [__] it
it hasn't changed that much yeah but the
focus of it is much more on the
investigation it's not really on him as
a person they don't ever really show him
other than when he gets arrested and he
has that mask on it's more about the law
enforcement officers and how they caught
him in the crimes and everything like
that soul looks a lot bigger and it they
have like modern technology now it's
it's it's neat it's like kind of like
Tokyo
yeah yeah but Wilder I think it's less
well not really Wilder that's that's
they got some wild [__] in Tokyo too I
just I just wild I'd rather go to Tokyo
I'd rather go to uh to Soul than
Tokyo I would kind of like to go to both
places eventually if you want to go
we'll go we'll go to Korea it just takes
us a long flight I know that's kind of
buming me out I don't want to do it all
in one go we would have more fun and it
would cost a lot less in in in um so
yeah it would cost a it's a fra fraction
fraction of the cost yeah I can imagine
yeah they got good food there they had
they had good food in 1990 yeah they
were good yeah and they got [__]
Wilder clubs you have fun there oh I'm
sure we had a friend that went there as
a tutor he didn't know how to he didn't
know how to have fun there he didn't
date Korean girls he goes to Korea and
he doesn't date Korean girls I'm like
what the [__] are you talking about he's
trying to dat she's trying to date
Western foreign women there they don't
want anything to do with that dude I
mean I did think that was a little
strange but whatever crazy whatever
crazy but yeah so um so yeah but so when
his wife had divorced him he had
apparently considered killing her um but
then so he was you know pissed off prior
to that but then when this girlfriend
left him saying like nah you have a
criminal record I'm not getting involved
in this like that was just kind of like
the straw that broke the camel's back I
guess uh one of his most famous quotes
which if you know anything about him you
probably heard this he actually said
this out loud uh when he got caught
because like I said he wasn't ashamed of
it he seemed kind of proud of it he
wanted everybody to know when they
caught him and he confessed all the
crimes and everything he said women
should not be [__] yeah and the rich
should know what they have done yeah
like everyone would be like yeah man
yeah right on dude that's not what
happened obviously but that's I I kind
of got the feeling that he thought that
that's what would happen it was funny
that the that that the women should not
be SL I thought it was funny that the
police would allow allow him to address
the media unscripted not knowing what he
was going to say well maybe they were
like ah give him enough rope to hang
himself
with let him say all kind of stupid [__]
and everybody would be like horrified
earlier on in the show I said that I
could hear through the tone in his voice
that was the
statement that uh Jen's talking about
where he's saying you know don't you
should learn if you learn anything from
this you women shouldn't be [__] and
you rich people you know what you all
did and just the way he says it it s it
sounds like it sounds like a smart
tarded [__] [__]
[__] yeah hey don't don't don't
cast dispersions on smarted people
because I am smarted yeah he's [__]
like you could tell he's he's uh kind of
hesitant in his in his words and uh kind
of unsure and insecure with himself
saying that it came off as
uh like he didn't believe what he just
said you know what I'm talking about
yeah it's kind of like yeah you don't
believe that dude you just [__] said
that [__]
that was just his explanation y'all
should learn from this don't be a [__]
and you rich people you know what you
did man shut the [__] up pretty much
well that's kind of how I feel about a
lot of these [__] when they
come out with these manifestos or
whatever I'm just like well no some
dudes have come out with some brilliant
ass Man Ted kazinsky Manifesto was like
something out of [__] Blade Runner
all right um he's still crazy as [__]
though yeah I don't know if he was I
don't know he might have been right
though about what corporations were
trying to do yeah but that does mean you
can just like blow up no wrong no he
should have been on he should have just
waited cuz YouTube would be around and
he'd have an awesome YouTube channel
he'd have been on Infowars [__] a
regular guest regular guest you know
[__] all these people would still be
alive and they yeah yeah that that's
that gets back we're going I'm gonna
repeat this again just for as a
disclaimer and I've said it many times
on this
show violent acts of terrorism are
always unproductive always
and it's also out of style that [__]
only worked in the pre and it barely
worked in the pre- internet era they
would do these attacks and these
explosions to try to get out a message
and the message rarely got out because
they would hide the message any message
that did get out is because they
released it to not the police or the
government they released it to like
Playboy magazine or some [__] like
that and still just because his message
got out that didn't mean people took it
seriously well cuz here's the dumb thing
you put out your quote unquote message
it's like oh I got everyone's attention
I'm like yeah you got everyone's
attention for what a murderous cron you
are no one's going to take you seriously
now even if you were right right it's
counterproductive physical Warfare
there's a time and a place for it
political terrorism is always kind of
[__] like the losing strategy all
right what's better is information
Warfare you buy a radio station or a
television station or a [__] YouTube
channel and you just plot away at it it
years and years and years to change the
culture to change the perceptions of of
the people that works and you're not
going to do that by blowing somebody up
or [__] killing people with hammers
and [__] you know no that's why I'm
saying when he said that [__] to the
public he knew he was lying he knew that
that was just [__] to me it reminded me
of remember when when we did the show
about fck Elliot Roger and his whole
thing like he wrote This Big Manifesto
I'm going to go take revenge on women
for not going out with me and just
shoots random people I'm like dude it
didn't work no and it's like and one and
you're not important no like all
everybody knows about you is you're some
crazy stupid [__] who shot
people because you could get laid that's
all anybody remembers about you what
would have been much more effective if
Elliot Rogers had a YouTube channel and
just ploted away every day posted a
video of him [__] talking [__] and
whining
and he have thousands of little [__]
yeah he would well because there's other
dudes that talk that that say that same
[__] and they have like lots of he would
have become like a meme maybe you know
what I mean and [__] and then his
message would get out and he he'd been
but a message like that is never going
to like take yeah everyone's going to
make fun of that because it's lame what
could have happened though is maybe if
he became a meme he maybe would have got
a
girlfriend some girl might have [__]
then he would have shut the [__] up then
he' shut the [__] up because some girl
would have go oh you know I know what
you're talking about you're full of [__]
watch go on a date with me and I'll show
you you know what I mean I'll show you
how full of [__] but she might have been
crazy too you know what I mean then next
you know you got these two crazy
[__] you know but like I said
it might have got him to like shut the
[__]
uput would um yeah every time when I was
a kid going man I'd do this I'd blow
that up know looking back on it I like
man [__] like no that wouldn't have
worked that's a very childlike response
it is very child of [__] violence it
it doesn't work unless it's part of the
plan to suck to unless you want the
blowback that comes after you like some
dudes will go out and commit a crime
because they want the cops to come kill
them yeah all right it's a it's a
suicide but that's not IR rational
that's not but that's what's going to
happen that's what's that that's that's
the realistic I mean if that's your end
goal then fine you can do that but it's
like you
know Zach says I love it when people
talk as if they assume everyone else
already knows what they mean yeah um
isn't that awesome when that happens I
love that too DVD Dragon said dude has
pizza cutter philosophy all Edge no
point
yeah like a pizza cut all Edge no point
that's a good one I'm try to remember
that that's a good one yeah yeah also he
says Korean food is the bomb they [__]
up some barbecue yeah the food was good
I'm still trying Miss Lee not here she
might remember man my [__] katusa
buddy he took me to a place and soul to
get some food that he said it wasn't
Korean but Koreans eat it he said it was
more like
Chinese and it was some kind of creamy
looking sauce in a big metal bowl that
had a fire underneath it like Sterno
fire and it had vegetables and then it
had these noodles that were about an
inch and a half two inches long and they
were thick they were fat they were chewy
it was almost like mozzarella cheese but
it was like a dumpling or a big long
Noodle and I don't know what it's called
I want to find it again it Koreans eat
it but it's not a Korean dish it's got
big and it's white white creamy gravy
looking I don't think it's got any cream
in it maybe it does but it is kind of
gray I remember it being kind of like
Gray colored with these big long noodles
they were fat it was and they were chewy
to a Westerner that was kind of like
chewy like mozzarella
cheese we were eating that man it was
[__] great
I can't remember what he told me what it
was but it was a long time ago I can't
remember what it was I've been trying to
find
it cuz I'd make it yeah you know you've
made um other Korean dishes youve made
like bulog yeah that's really yeah
that's really good that's the main one
I'd make yeah Korean barbecue it's real
good and I'll do that same recipe with
pork tenderloin it's good too yeah
because it's so much cheaper than
beef marinade Coca-Cola it's good both
ways it has it's pear right with you
have it with pairs pear they they use
something it's a different kind of pear
it's like a little Korean pair little
miniature
ones Zach said there was this place in
Hawaii we'd get food sometimes they did
box lunches yeah they do that a lot in
Hawaii don't they tons of food and cheap
as [__] so damn good I wish box lunch
places were a thing around here yeah
they're really not and I kind of feel
like that would I mean not around here
anyways the only place I know like the
Japanese place up the street they do
Bento boxes for lunch and those are like
pretty good but they don't really have
like a lot of box lunch places but
that's real big in Hawaii though isn't
it so uh so yeah where were we so yeah
women should not be [__] um according
to this [__] so oh okay yeah
don't be [__] and I won't kill you
we'll stop it whatever [__] off weenie
so um so apparently yeah so you have to
think that his wife who had divorced him
uh was a sex worker she had previously
she had worked in massage parlor and his
girlfriend was also an escort she worked
in what was called a telephone room
which I think was kind of the same thing
as being an escort so they're
speculating that he probably targeted
women that reminded him of them like the
women that had [__] him over so he's
going to punish all women for the quote
unquote crimes of two specific women
which makes total sense kind of a
reoccurring theme in serial killers it
really is I don't well and here's
another thing where you're going back to
what how um you know a lot of dudes and
serial killers in particular can't
really see things from a women's point
of view they also tend to see women as
like a hive mind or like or like a
single entity because if like like yeah
if like one woman [__] them over then
they're all like that then they're all
like that and so they have to punish
them all like as a proxy for the one
woman that [__] them over like the one
individual woman which is dumb as hell
but you know and heaven forbid that
woman [__] you over because you did
something wrong around that woman and
she just changed her ways to protect
herself from your crazy ass that's proba
that's what I'm saying and I think 99%
of because especially like a lot of the
dudes that think that way are [__] up
and so the women have every [__]
understandable reaction to that person
and it's just like yeah I'm just going
to like back away slowly or whatever but
somehow that's them being crazy or them
that's their fault or them [__] the
dude over even though the dude obviously
did some [__] to
uh to kind of like encourage that but of
course it's never their fault it's
always her fault so I kind of feel like
that's another recurring theme with
these type of dudes look man these same
dudes that get pissed off that the women
don't want to give them any play are the
same guys that aren't giv play to 80 or
90 year old woman you go well I don't
want to [__] that old that woman she's
too old she's not attractive well this
young woman that's running from you
doesn't find you attractive right you
know so see works both ways so you're
you're you you know what I mean we also
people there's a reason why she you know
you have to have some introspection okay
you struck out with that one why what
did you do wrong yeah you know what I
mean if like think about it well a lot
of times is that the girl's out of your
league okay and the dude's like well how
she had she's hot yeah but you you're
not okay you're like 30 pounds
overweight all right you never been to
the [__] gym you don't hardly have
any money and you definitely don't have
a [__] personality okay all that can
be fixed it's just that it takes effort
they don't want to do that though same
dude that want the same dudes that want
these hot women don't want to work to
get them right see you got to have
something to offer but then like they
don't and but then they get mad and like
blame the women when the women don't
want to go out with them oh up to all
women they're [__] all they want is
money and blah blah blah which is not
true then turns around doesn't want to
go out with that 75y old woman who's
looking at him or he wouldn't even go
out with a like a quote unquote like you
know ug
or not attractive women his own age yeah
right yeah so it's like so he doesn't
really have any room to complain yeah
that's what I mean they always want like
the hottest of the hot but they don't
really want to do anything to like quote
unquote deserve that yeah or why would
or why would that be attractive to
somebody that could go out with anybody
pretty much well it's just like just
like I was saying earlier on they only
see things from their point of view have
anyy they can't see anything from other
people's point of view you have to be
able to put yourself in the of someone
else and see like well how would they
see this situation and they don't know
the game anyway they've been instructed
improperly on what the game is they
don't know how how hypergamy Works they
don't know how competition works you
know because really dating is is dating
and mating is a competition as in in all
animal kingdoms and we're in the human
animal kingdom and you've got you've got
to
compete uh you will rise or fall to your
appropriate level in that system if
you're a [__] five you don't stand a
chance of getting a woman that's a seven
not a chance you just
don't a girl who's a Sev going out with
guys who are
eights you know that's just how it is
they go the other svens they either go
out with a guy who's a seven or a dude
that's a eight women only date over or
up they don't date down no
way all right where was
I okay so after this point like I said
so after the girlfriend left him after
all of this kind of stuff and he decides
well I'm just going to start taking it
out on other escorts yeah so it was at
this point pretty much that he kind of
got into his second Mo which was calling
up escort services massage parlors or
whatever ordering a girl having her come
to the apartment and then he would kill
them in the apartment now before that
started happening though I should note
that he would also kill people just for
like convenience purposes so there was a
couple like that too because on February
5th of
2004 he stabbed a 47-year-old man named
uh CH Chung Young day to death um I
believe this was the case I think he was
a street vendor and I think that he
because
cuz Yu young ch um he had like a police
badge or police uniform or something he
would go around telling people he was
cop like to get his way like in certain
they didn't really go a lot into this in
the
documentary and I think that this
particular guy was like you're not
really a cop or something like that so
he killed him uh he stabbed him to death
yeah that was his first one so that well
that was the one in this series yeah
like but you know so so like I said it
wasn't all sex work it was mostly sex
workers in this in this uh period but he
killed killed other people too like just
because it was convenient or they were
on to him or something let me answer
Bryce Bryce says women don't date down
in terms of look of looks uh yeah they
do it depends the number that I gave is
the woman's overall number yeah that's
not just looks it's not just looks that
there's a lot of factors the dude might
not look that good but he's got high
status and a great personality and she
likes him so she might give him a higher
number than you would being a man just
looking at him from a physical
standpoint yeah because we look we look
at a lot of different metrics yeah it's
just a man's overall number and being a
millionaire and being funny your [__]
gets bumped up very high yeah yeah
especially if you're famous then it
starts getting bumped up yeah so uh no
women are not as visually stimulated as
guys are not saying they're not at all
but significantly less it's just one of
the things and let me tell you a guy's
looks will not seal the deal it'll get
you in the
door you might get laid that doesn't
mean she's going to be a repeat customer
and you're gonna have a relationship
with her she might just try you out and
then go nah I don't really like this guy
he's a douche [__] is great I [__] it
but I don't want to I don't want [__]
this dude cuz women will do that too I
don't know I don't know like but I don't
know if guys think that's just a guy
thing but women wom do that too yep
there's like yeah he's hot but n he was
kind of an [__] I didn't really want
to put up with his ass he's not that and
then she replaced that dude with a dude
who actually physically doesn't look as
good but he's cool yeah and and maybe
he's going places and a little more
interesting got a better personality cuz
I would much rather yeah um a dude that
was like qu kind of funny looking but
was like real interesting or funny or or
had a lot in common or something like
that than some dude that was like a
super hot like 10 but was kind of a jerk
yeah yeah um well even Zach said it
right there Zach says [__] good
personality covers up a lot it does yeah
I did Tammy say that um Tammy said that
Tammy said that it does actually mostly
a woman
thing uh women are not as heavily
leaning on the visual aspect yeah if you
have other [__] going on um that makes
you like way sexier right like if you're
like I said if you're funny or you have
like a really good or you're super
laidback or we have a lot in common and
we can like talk about stuff and
everything like that like it doesn't
matter as much as it would to a dude I
guess that dude could be [__] 6' two
look like [__] Batman just mother
just [__] hot as [__] [__]
physically and everything but if he
opens his mouth just says a bunch of
stupid [__] she's going to shut him down
yeah and'll get him in the door and then
she'll shut that door and like I said
she might [__] him one time yeah and
then she'd be like then she be then she
be like calling her friends to's like oh
my God yeah I [__] him he was he was
good but that [__] him I no thanks yeah
it's like I had to listen to him talk
about some boring ass [__] here's
something else that [__] blew my mind
the female friends have told me they
will lower their standards to [__] some
dude just to get laid but they would
never [__] go out with with that dude
then the next night they meet a guy that
they like and they raise their standards
up and be because they take him
seriously and if he doesn't make
it she'll blow his ass off too even
though she was more interested in that
guy she [__] the dude she didn't like
and then turned down the guy she did
like that's the crazy he didn't try hard
enough he didn't try hard enough he
didn't pass my tests that [__]
well like I said she liked him M well I
don't understand why don't understand
that more because that's kind of the
same thing that dudes do no that is not
a guy well I mean it's similar to what
dudes no guy will [__] them all well I
know that but I'm just saying she would
at Le a guy would at least go yeah this
one I like I'm a [__] you know the
other one that I didn't like I'm a
[__] too I'm not going to go back to
this one this one I like I'm G [__] this
one a couple times and
yeah I don't she really didn't measure
up but I'm just going to ride this for a
little while cuz I don't have anything
else going on and uh when I get sick of
her I'll get rid of her so at least she
got some but in the in the but the
dude's situation the other reverse
situation is that she likes this dude so
she raises her standards much higher and
he doesn't meet the standards and then
she kicks him to the
curb that's a weird thing only women
would think that way well like I said we
have a lot more concerns than men do
they're afraid CU that woman likes that
guy and they're afraid well if he
doesn't quite measure up I might get
pregnant by this guy yeah and then
you're stuck so I got to get rid of him
like forever yeah like I said we have a
lot more practical concerns than dudes
do dudes can just go around spraying
sperm everywhere and it's fine but it's
just kind of like yeah they don't really
have any repercussions so the number the
number the the women the numbers that
women give to men is an overall number
in general the number that men give to
women is more of a physical number
that's looks more looks yeah but when a
woman says oh he well I don't think a
lot of women are um as r dtive as that
um but maybe if they do they usually
mean a lot more than just looks if a
dude says that it's usually just looks
but if we say that I don't say that
because I think that's silly but you
know what I mean because it's I don't
know it just seems like a dumb like I
said it seems reductive to me it's like
I don't know that [__] person you
know seems weird to like give them a
number score whether it's their looks or
whatever I I don't I don't know I I
don't think of those terms but yeah so
um so yeah so because this
dude's wife had worked as a masseuse or
worked in a massage parlor which like I
said I'm assuming is kind of like an
escort and because his girlfriend had
also worked as an escort which he knew
here's another thing he knew this prior
to marrying the first woman and prior to
dating the second woman presumably um so
he didn't have a problem with it then
but apparently like after they [__]
him
over from his point of view obviously
they probably just like yeah you're
crazy and you have this huge like um
criminal record so by which like I said
is a completely reasonable reaction um
but from his point of view they [__]
him over so it's like that is just like
[__] all women everywhere I'm just going
to kill them all so it was that kind of
situation I you know I and and he
especially wanted to Target women in
that profession because he thought they
were [__] like I said this is a very
common serial killer mindset they really
do a lot of them do seem to have BTK had
like a lot of other ones have that
Madonna horor complex where it's like
well we have the saintly women like you
know the ones that are married are like
oh like my wife or my mom or whatever um
but then all the other ones are just
hores and you can just do whatever you
want with them I kind of feel like they
have that there's only two kinds of
women for them like it's very binary
which I don't I don't really get that
but okay so uh so yeah so as I said he
also killed for convenience cuz he
killed this one guy who I'm pretty sure
that this guy that he killed I think it
was because he called him out on his
like that's not a real police badge or
that's not a real police uniform or
something like that um now the day after
this happened cuz that happened on
February 5th 2004 the day after that
happened this was kind of interesting
and I don't think they mentioned this on
the documentary maybe they did and I
didn't catch it but the day after that
February 6th there was a 24-year-old
woman um named Gian hiio Sil and she was
stabbed to death while she was walking
down the street now later on after they
caught um Yu young chol he actually
confessed to that crime but it was
subsequently discovered that that was
actually a victim of another serial
killer who was operating like a little
bit of an overlap there uh whose name
was Jong Nam gu now he actually killed
14 people between 2004 and
2006 so that turned out to be one of his
victims but Yu young CH like initially
took credit for that you know cuz just
this girl that was walking on the street
that got stabbed so so there was that
now March uh 16th I believe that says
March 16th or 18th I'm getting like it's
kind of blurry um he killed another girl
a 23-year-old uh named Quan jinhe um he
called for her like called for a girl he
would always request ones that were
short and slight uh and this was because
and this is a [__] up reason this was
because he thought it would make him
easier to dispose of the bodies if they
were small so he didn't want ones that
were tall or he didn't ones that were
chubby or anything like that so he
wanted ones that were real little I
think it's funny
CU having hunted a lot of deer and field
dressed a lot of deer [__] you know
dressed them out butcher style all nice
and clean there's not much difference
between animals of different sizes it's
all about the same so I don't really
know what he's talking about it's in his
mind well there no difference between
three or four inches in a woman yeah
each little part's only going to be a
little bit longer guess are going to be
just a little a little bit longer and
cuz the the difference in the height per
bone isn't very much right it adds up
well he probably wasn't thinking of it
he's crazy yeah he's crazy it didn't
make a difference once you're once
you're cutting up an animal which is
what he did to these poor women yeah
he's basically dressing them yeah get
out of what he would do he would call
for one and they would come to his house
like his apartment he would have sex
with them like they would do the
transaction
and then you feed them too yeah they
like a lot of times he would like just
heat up some noodles in the microwave or
whatever so it wasn't like he wasam
right yeah like some or some [__] like
that so it wasn't like he was being all
like fancy or nothing but he would at
least give him some like pot noodle or
whatever so so they would eat dinner he
would have sex with them and then
afterward when they got up to go in the
bathroom he would essentially like
follow them into the bathroom and they
said on the documentary that he admitted
that the threshold between the bedroom
and the bathroom like the door threshold
he thought he called that the threshold
between life and death yeah because like
the women would go in the bathroom and
he would follow them in there and Bash
them in the head with his [__]
Sledgehammer thing and then he would
start cutting them up he would cut off
their
heads he would put all of their hair
like in a ponytail like in a rubber band
on the top yeah on the top he would cut
their heads off and then would like hang
the head like on the toilet paper holder
yeah to like drain the blood out or cuz
he wanted to look at it or I'm not
really sure why he's he's thinking that
draining the blood out will make the
whole thing lighter lighter I guess you
know when you do that to a deer it's not
much you know there's not much blood in
the body really maybe gallon so doesn't
really save that much weight he's just
being ritualistic if you ask me he's
getting off on seeing the body being
dismembered it's a power thing
got to be yeah and you know I know maybe
he's not a real powerful guy he's kind
of slight women don't weigh much
especially little Korean women you know
pounds I don't know I don't understand a
man can't carry 120 pounds but he's
going to try to get her out of there in
a in a in a
[__] um
taxi oh I'll get into that in a minute
yeah which you would think you just put
them in a pretty large suitcase told her
up put it in a suitcase that'd be fine
but he's going through all this
dismemberment I think it's I think it's
a fetish it does seem very fetishistic
because you don't really have to go
through all of that um and honestly I
wouldn't I'm not a serial killer clearly
but it's like if I wouldn't do all
because it makes too much of a mess I
mean there's just too much one it's too
much effort yeah it's too much effort
it's too much work it leaves too much
evidence behind you're going to get
blood everywhere it's like it's too hard
to clean up which you know he's doing it
in the shower and it looks spotlessly
clean but they go in there with luminol
you could see that he all ceiling see
that was another thing he's like he
doesn't know about luminol come on but
here's the thing you got to look at it
from his point of view that didn't get
him caught right he was already caught
when they found that well yeah um cuz
yeah he had killed a bunch of women at
least like 9 10 11 he would have walked
had he just kept his [__] mouth shut
he wanted to get caught he wanted to get
caught yeah I mean that's the thing
yeah so so yeah so that's what he would
do he would cut their heads off he'd
hang them on the toilet paper holder and
then he would cut up the rest of their
bodies and put him in bags and I'll get
into that in a minute but so the first
one that he did like that that CU that
was kind of hismo like going forward um
was March 16th however almost a month
after that April 14th he killed another
person that was just kind of like a
crime of convenience or just because
somebody pissed him off and this was a
guy named um anjon he was 44 and he was
another like street vendor he had like a
truck of some kind and he had actually
scammed allegedly uh Yu uh Yu young CH
by giving him fake Viagra I guess and um
you didn't know that [__] was fake yeah
I guess not okay so um apparently you
was pretty pissed about this so he goes
to the van and they got into an argument
and then he ended up um pretty much like
shoving the guy into his own van like
put handcuffs on him and murdered him
like stabbed him to death he then he
like saw his hands off and put him in a
plastic bag and like chucked him
somewhere and then he set the van on
fire yeah now the sad thing about this
is that they had the brother of this of
this victim was on the documentary yeah
now he had two other brothers both of
those Brothers committed suicide because
of this and he tried to commit suici
side too but he changed his mind at the
last he was saved by dogs he yeah he was
like out in the woods and he was going
to kill himself and then he found an
abandoned dog yeah he took care of the
dog that I don't that made me tear up a
little bit that whole thing I was just
cuz he still has the dogs now that
something's been known in the VA and
[__] uh you could give guys who have
PTSD pets yeah something to take care of
yeah and it takes a lot of stress off
them because now they can care for
something and and then they're like it's
kind of like uh holding him hostage well
if I died nobody's GNA take care of my
dog yeah yeah so you know what I mean
then they have a relationship with a dog
or a cat and they're better than kids
because it's like they're not as much H
turn on you right well that's the thing
that's why a lot of people like dogs
because it's like you know unconditional
they just love you whatever it's like
you know what I mean you could be [__]
up and they're just like I just I love
you anyway you know what I mean so it's
like that's really healing for people so
the fact that he told that story that he
actually went out in the woods to commit
suicide as his two other brothers had
done yeah and he actually tried to kill
this [__] too like when he like he
went out there with his shirt off and he
had a knife and he like jumped on the
front of the van and they had footage of
it yeah and he and he was he stacked
Korean style little short VT [__]
like that well he was a little big man
yeah he he's probably about my size and
[__] but you know 56 and [__] he
he was built uh and it looked like all
Natty all natural he wasn't on anything
uh he wasn't on any performance
enhancers he [__] does a frontal
assault on the damn van where they were
holding the serial killer the cops are
pulling it back and he's putting on a
[__] Big Show he's got a knife and
everything you know they didn't charge
him good thing but well I mean he he he
was going to fight I don't think anybody
here would either cuz they're like they
felt bad for him most people would do
the same thing but yeah the fact that he
said that he just went out in the woods
to kill himself also yeah and then found
an abandoned dog and he felt like well I
can't do it now because I have to rescue
this dog yeah he was cool dude he was
cool dude yeah he seemed like went a
[__] R sh man [__] hell and they were
saying too that you know during this
time period because they didn't really
have this kind of crime in Korea they're
like we didn't really have the resources
to like help victim's families either
because like people didn't really go
through this type of thing like in Korea
prior to this so there so that's another
thing that's improved since this time is
that now they have more resources and
victims compensation and things like
that they didn't have that back then so
it was a lot harder yeah they said that
they learned a lot from that yeah how
how to handle with with the uh the V the
families the the families of the victims
yeah Korea didn't really have a system
for that yeah because they hadn't really
had to have one right because they
didn't really have anything like this
that happened before there's uh you got
to worry about the survivors Survivor
guilt a lot of these dudes [__] kill
themselves because they feel like they
failed that they couldn't protect him
yeah that's exactly they couldn't that
they weren't there they couldn't they
weren't there when they should have been
they couldn't that that they could have
stopped it but they weren't there so
it's like a Survivor guil even though I
mean obviously they probably couldn't
have like obviously the [__] would have
happened anyway but it's just kind of
they were there they could have stopped
it they might have been able to there's
no way how could they have known to be
there mean but it just it still haunts
them you know and I can totally see that
I can totally see that yeah and that's
what's so messed up about it that's why
it's so important to like have that kind
of you know those kind of resources for
victim's families and stuff which now
they have but they didn't have back then
when this happened yeah criminals this
kind of criminal only strikes when
you're not there you know it's just them
and the woman or them and the victim
that was kind of his whole thing yeah
like he would even the whole families
that he attacked yeah early on in his
criminal career if you want to call it
they were like elderly they were like in
their 70s and 80s it was the middle of
the day like nobody else was like all
the other people in the neighborhood
were at work it was that kind of thing
and it's a sneak attack that too he's
not going in there with a firearm
blasting off and everybody in the house
can hear it he just runs in and [__]
pow hits somebody
runs back up pow hits somebody else and
some comes down the stairs he grabs him
pow and hits him you know
so uh something like a hammer if you're
fast and you know and he was fast and
agile much faster more agile than these
people in the 70s and their 80s he's
moving like lightning they don't stand a
chance yeah you know that's what's
[__] sad about it he's getting off on
it you know yeah I'm the Punisher I'm
taking care of these rich people he's in
living in his own little fantasy world
that is all Justified he's getting even
yeah but it doesn't take anything from
him didn't even take any money evidently
no he didn't take anything yeah so it
was [__] if you ask me he he's not
poor he's not really
poor uh he was living okay had a little
apartment and everything you know it's
just resentment jealousy although here's
the thing I was wonder where he was
getting his money from because he' been
in and out of prison like pretty much
since he was a teenager I don't don't
know if he had a
job so I don't know not really sure like
how I don't know what that whole
situation was I kind of wondered about
that they didn't really say what he did
they didn't really say I don't think he
had a job I think how he got money
before was through like fraud and stuff
they showed his apartment it was it was
decent little apartment yeah it wasn't
like a [__] hole or anything no and the
uh got the police said that his
apartment was spotless yeah they thought
maybe he was a neat freak yeah he was a
neat freak well there was a reason for
that yeah he had killed a bunch of women
in there yeah he killed a bunch of women
in there and he was kept it clean but I
think he was also a control
freak and uh control freaks are also
kind of like neat freaks but I don't
want to talk about bad about them
because I'm like that too I like
everything [__] you know having a
military background I like everything
[__] squared away and Ship Shape you
know what the Navy would say uh in the
Army we call it squared away I like
everything clean and orderly and in its
right place and everything folded and
you know I'll [__] come in here I
vacuum and I got a damn Electrolux
vacuum and an Electrolux [__] carpet
shampoo I just went in here and
shampooed the carpet in here I like
everything to kind of have a nice smell
like I'm in a in an office or a you know
nice hotel that's where I like it so he
was like that um but I think with him
you know it was part of kind of a
malevolent control you know part of the
aspects
part of aspect of his
personality
um and what was weird is that he was not
a bad-looking guy he was a good-looking
guy and he was uh he did have the
ability the ability for talent he could
draw but he was so wrapped Loser yeah he
was so wrapped up in his delusions and
the way he's looking at the
world that he went very sideways he went
real negative
and
um he was blaming Society at
large for his [__]
shortcomings for his failures I feel
like that's more of a thing like some
serial killers do that I feel like
that's more of a spree killer thing like
like Mass Shooters and stuff yeah they
tend to be e like real paranoid like
that or like everyone's out to get me or
everyone's [__] me over you might be
able to say that this might have been
something like a spree here it and
that's what I was going to say was that
this you know even though it happened
over you know almost a year it was 10
months but it was still kind of like a
spree because really there wasn't much
time in between the crimes it was only
like a few weeks few weeks since and
then he would do it and then he would do
it again and do it again and then there
was like a three-month Gap and then he
would do it like you know within a few
days of each other so he wasn't like a
typical serial killer where it was he
was doing this for years and years
sometimes decades it was only a year and
he was doing it quite
regularly and what was weird is
that the motive wasn't
sexual he could have sex he did have sex
with he had sex with him he also had he
had wives and Ex-Wives so the motives
didn't seem to be sexual he would have
sex with them normally and pay for it he
could just let him go yeah he could have
just let him walk out of there no he he
had to kill him
afterwards which is that most serial
killers don't do that most serial
killers are killing them during a kind
of like a sexual thing because that's
part of the part of their thing of how
they get off right it's a s you know a
lot of them are sadistic sexual s sexual
sadists and that's not what he was doing
this is like a punishment thing yeah
it's exact well he said that yeah he I
think he used that exact word
right
which [__] stupid well yeah I mean
all of their motives they don't make any
sense to us because we're normal people
you know but it's just kind of like but
I mean intellectually like I understand
how any how somebody could come to that
it's just that I don't think like that
so it seems alien to me but if you
explain it to me I get it how is
punishing her going to change anything
yeah well and that's another thing too I
think millions of those that's what I
mean and I think a lot of the thing too
is that another thing that a lot of
serial killers and a lot of mass
Shooters and people like that have is
they have this overinflated sense of
their own importance so they think that
anything they do is going to be like
this big Earth shattering and he even
said like he even said yeah like I'm
going to tell you this is going to like
crack the earth into or whatever the
[__] he said I'm going tell you this is
going to turn going to turn the world
upside down to turn the whole world or
something like that and it's just like
no it probably won't like everyone's
just going to be horrified but then no
and all he was saying is I cut this girl
apart it's going to turn the world up in
America that's nothing for serial
killers serial killers they do that [__]
time sad yeah in American serial kill
done much worse than that like the
murderers were [__] some of the [__]
that they did I was like I can't [__]
believe it [__] some of the [__] that
they did to those girls while they were
alive he didn't do anything to these
girls while they were alive he killed
them with a h blow of a hammer almost
damn near instantly so you he wasn't not
that that makes it any better I'm he
wasn't a torturer the yeah he wasn't
getting off on the torture yeah Mur long
long distance long range torture of
[__] young girls [__] with with
with pliers and ice piics and [__] like
that and uh you know those girls knew
what was happening and they would record
it and [__] on on a couple occasions you
know and they were
just I just my [__] blood boils when
I think of that [__] man because I want
those dudes so badly when I see but I
think a lot of guys are like that well
yeah well I'm like that I'm like oh my
God if you put me in a room with those
[__] [__] Jesus Christ
because I can I'm willing to go to jail
for that well the thing about it like
and I write about cases like that and
it's like sometimes I try to
deliberately like put myself in the
shoes of the victim like what would it
have been like for that victim for that
V like oh my God it's like [__]
horrifying like to think about it cuz
I'm pretty good at like putting myself
in other people's situations and it's
like that's just oh that [__] me up
thinking about you know I've taken
serious damage before in motorcycles and
fights and [__] usually what happens is
you don't feel a damn thing because your
[__] adrenaline is so I just hope
that is the case the camera is shaking
that you just kind of like they just
check out [__] shut down I think they
do hopefully your body would at least
give you that [__] Mercy I would
think they just kind of mentally escape
from but if it doesn't then I can't
imagine GH I have a feeling they mostly
just kind of shut down because just the
psychological and emotional trauma of
what's happening to them they just go
into shock cuz I was yeah and I have
thought that before I was like Jesus
Christ if I was ever in that situation I
would just hope that I would just go and
just like I'm going somewhere else you
just kind of mentally Retreat I would
hope so but like I said not everybody
can do that I guess like that's not
Universal well animals seem to be able
to do it while they're being eaten alive
I think it's called Su and it's where
you see lions eating a zebra alive
because they're one of them is choking
the LI the zebra out and then the other
lions are already [__] taking big
bites out of its legs and [__] you'll
see the zebra's eyes roll back into it
head sometime that's called Su and uh
when prey animals are under real high
stress they just blank out you know so I
think it's just something that nature
has given them to
escape the horrors are being eaten alive
by cute gigantic kitty
cats when you think about it lions are
cats are cute they eat [__] alive they
eat things alive they're from the point
of view of the prey they're monsters
well they don't call kittens murder
muffins for nothing yeah you
know so nature is like
that kill and be killed not or but and
every Everything dies eventually it's
killed by something if you die of
sickness that's the Nature's equivalent
of you're basically being eaten by bugs
you die of sickness you
know so everything is killed I mean in a
way humans are kind of like lucky
because most of us di of like probably
not as B it's probably better than being
eaten alive I would imagine we die of
sicknesses usually which is by bugs yeah
they now when they know it's coming they
give you so much morphine you're just
[__] high as [__] thank [__] man I
wouldn't wanted to live back in the old
days [__] that [__] but um well they had
that in the old days
too um
but I think what sucks is if you were
dying of cancer back back then before
all that I think they just killed
themselves blood leting keep leing blood
out until they [__] die well and and
like I said especially back in those in
those days when the when the medical um
you know uh Technologies were uh less
than ideal let's put it that way um
probably they'd be like you know what
doc just just [__] kill me yeah let
the let Blood Out just just let it keep
coming out until I go to sleep and it'll
be fine like and they probably do if
they did that they probably did that
like I said it would have been a mercy
there'd be no records of that right yeah
well yeah they don't want that getting
out right even nowadays people are a
little weird about it but it's just kind
of like still I don't I don't blame
people for going that rout IPR me if
ancient doctors performed youth an Asia
without saying anything yeah because
they would know how to do it like I said
people are still weirded out by it which
I don't really get but okay bad dunwell
is here and said this stream is like
when you meet two really cool people at
the bar and you guys are chatting and
vibing it's like that thank you that's
kind of what we I don't even know if we
were like trying to do the show like
that that was just how the show turned
out no we kind of said we were going to
be say we be online friends and we're
gonna [__] talk about all this [__]
and we're going to have regulars yeah
that's how it happened and we're just
being yeah ourselves like we're not I
grew up listening to radio artbell and
[__] Howard Stern back when he was
relevant and [__] you know I just
like that radio feel radio is
[__] irrelevant now it's all going to
be YouTube but I mean it's the same kind
of thing because people still listen to
podcasts and stuff so it's pretty much
the same thing yeah the show is also out
there in podcast form yeah I usually put
the audio version out there too like I
think it's on Apple and some other [__]
right but uh but yeah so this
[__] so so like I said so he
cuts the heads off he puts the hair in a
ponytail hangs them on the toilet paper
holder for whatever reason and then he
puts the bodies in the tub and starts
cutting them up so all of the bodies are
cut into you know like 17 18 pieces
interestingly after he got caught like a
bunch of the other because he lived in
an apartment they said it was on the
third floor right he he lived in a third
floor apartment and I guess all of the
um their water bills were just kind of
like they just took like the water for
the whole building and just split it
evenly like between all the units and so
people were starting to complain that
their water bills were going up because
one unit was using more a lot more water
than usual and it turned out it was his
because I guess he was rinsing the
bodies off or rinsing all the blood out
or like washing all the blood out of his
apartment like of all these women that
he killed in there so he's cutting up
all these bodies and then he would um
take off their fingerprints like he
would cut them off or sand them off or
whatever like so they couldn't be
identified as easily and then he would
put their pieces in garbage bags which
he eventually would take and bury them
like on this mountain which was like
behind this Temple I was thinking it was
like out in the middle of the woods but
when they showed the police photos of
the Dig of them like digging the remains
up and stuff it looked like it was like
literally like right behind a building
and I was just kind of like oh I was
thinking it was like out in the middle
of the [__] woods but it wasn't I
don't know how many people like went to
this Temple or whatever it might not
have been like you know there might not
have been people going there but it's
like the fact that he's just like
burying I think they found 11 bodies in
that burial ground that he was just
going there and like burying pieces of
women back there and like nobody knew
what he was up to it wasn't out in the
middle of nowhere it really wasn't I was
like surprised when I saw the still in
the city there was like a park what we
would call here in the United States a
park or an empty lot behind it it just
happened to be the empty lot was on a
hill it had a hill so it wasn't really
and it was all like foliage like trees
and like underbrush and stuff that Hill
kind of made it not really kind of like
good real estate for building on right
so it just was like the last resort
building place so it was still
wooded U but it was in the middle of
[__] City if you ask me it looked
like at least from our point of from the
photos that we saw they showed it on the
map yeah yeah yeah and it was still in
the middle of
soul and what he would do is he would go
in there he would bury a victim and he
would put a marker on the grave like a
bottle cap or something like that so he
would know not to dig in the same place
again cuz it was already a body there
I'm like how [__] [__] up is that he's
like he wanted to mark it with something
that no one would recognize so it's like
it was usually bottle caps and stuff
what's funny is that it rains in Korea
you would think that the bottle cash
would just be the bottle cap would just
been washed away so you're not talking
about a
genius yeah he wasn't nearly as smart as
he thought I think I would have put a
stick there with something tied on it
and things there that you could see that
they would something a little more long
term just kind of a just kind of a
indication that he's not that smart you
know yeah I definitely don't think he
was as smart as he thought he was but
claims 140 but none of those serial
killers are as smart as I think they are
140 is pretty smart U it is but come on
you have to understand that but he could
just things affected by he might have
been lying he might be more like 120 you
know but you because you would think
that yeah if I stick this bottle cap
here the rain will come and wash this
downhill but thing it was it was still
there though it was still there l so I
guess he wasn't as stupid as you how did
he keep it fixed to that area cuz they
were dig when when he took them to the
the bottle
cap they started digging and a downpour
came yeah and the the the rain the water
got all on the bodies and everything it
would they they never would have done
that in the US they would waited till
the [__] or they would at least put
like tarps and [__] like over the whole
area I kind of feel like like they
wouldn't want the rain to wash away any
any evidence yeah what if it was like
cigarette butts or something like that
like cuz they usually like Mark every
single little thing but in Korea's in
the defense of the Korean police they
weren't real experienced with deal
dealing with they had never done a case
like this before this was kind of like
their first ones and all these dudes
that dug up all these bodies they their
testimony was on this program which you
guys really should watch it U they were
traumatized seeing all those bodies come
up out of there they were all like cut
up and stuff and they were about a month
old
a couple months old some of them they
said the flesh was still there they were
pulling heads out bothered them yeah
they said it was [__] up and they said
it was [__] up because you know Y
young CH was there with them and he was
just like oh yeah that's so and so and
this is how I killed her and stuff and
he was just like real [__] casual
about it and they were just like and
that really like [__] Disturbed it
wasn't a big deal to him he was there
well yeah so it was
demystified honestly I kind of like that
the law enforcement officers in this
were is this weird to say that they were
like so upset by this yeah I was like
well at least they have a because I kind
of feel like a lot of American cops are
just like man whatever we've seen so
much that it's like they're they're just
completely desensitized are you going to
talk about his Escape yeah I haven't got
well I haven't got to that point yet I'm
still talking about the murders yeah
yeah yeah I probably need another drink
though you know what I mean all right so
yeah some of these cops in there where
they're in this program and there some
hardboiled [__] this one guy he's
hardboiled as [__] he's kind a tough guy
he [__] up though well yeah I love
that guy though he he was funny all the
actually all of the all of the cops in
this were actually
really and like I said the um the
documentary series like it's on Netflix
and it's called The ranco Killer I think
it came out in 2021 it's three episodes
and um it mostly focuses on the
investigation so it's very very focused
heavily on the law enforcement and them
talking about the investigation so it's
not so much focused on the killer um
it's more focused on the investigation
and the victims and like the crimes
themselves which in a way I kind of kind
of liked better they didn't Focus they
didn't talk anything about um Yu young
ch's uh past they didn't talk about his
prior criminal record they didn't really
talk about anything like that and it
seemed like they were trying to I don't
want to say like demystify him but they
were trying to like downplay him like I
guess they didn't want to like glorify
him maybe so they kind of focused more
on how they caught him like how they
investigated the crimes and H they
caught him so so yeah so he' cut the
bodies up he put them in garbage and
then he bury them in this spot that he
had and it was the same spot he buried
them they said he buried them just like
pretty much all in a line cuz he would
like Mark them now this kind of blew my
mind and I don't know if he did this
every time because I don't know if he
had a
vehicle but on at least one occasion at
least they mention this on the
documentary he had the pieces of the
body I don't think it was the entire
body because I think he took them out
like a little bit at a time from his
apartment so no when would get
suspicious but he would put some of the
body parts in the garbage bags and then
he called a
taxi to take him to the burial site like
where he was going to bury the bodies
that blew my [__] mind I'm like Okay
this [__] is not as smart as I come on
that is again a rooky
mistake but what he would do he thought
he was being clever I guess what he
would do is he would fill he you know he
had the bags that had you know [__]
body parts in them like you know arms
and legs or whatnot and he would put
kimchi in there which you know it smells
kind of bad and so if anybody asked him
like what are those stinky ass bags you
have it's like oh it's I have like
kimchi like my mom made it or you know
whatever and it's like she gave it to me
in these big garbage bags which to me
seems a little fishy maybe that happens
a lot in Korea I don't know here my mom
gave me two big garbage bags full of
kimchi that she had buried in the
backyard and like that fermented so it's
just kind of like but yeah so I don't
know if this was the first case or if he
did this every time cuz like I said I'm
not really sure if he had a vehicle so
I'm not really sure like how he got all
the body parts like out to the barrial
site but on at least one occasion he
took a cab and the cab driver absolutely
did ask him what is that [__] smell
like what is in those bags and he said
that it was kimchi and I guess the
driver bought it because he didn't
report it
so can you imagine being a serial killer
who has to rely on like public
transportation
there's a sitcom idea in there somewhere
I feel like it would be a very very dark
comedy admittedly but not going to lie
I'd probably watch it the serial killer
that has to ride the city bus and it's
like how do you I don't know there's
just something very absurd about the
thought of a serial killer having to use
public transportation to dispose of
bodies
yeah like I said I I just said I said
there's a sitcom in there somewhere yeah
yeah that is not an American
day yeah cuz can you imagine America can
you imagine cuz I used to have to ride
public transportation back in the old
days like before I had a car and it's
like so I'm riding if you're from the
you know Daytona Beach valuch County
area it was called the Votran it's still
around it's still around uh you'd ride
the Votran and it's like if some
[__] gets on there with two
garbage bags that smelled like kimchi um
I think everybody be like that's a
[__] body get the [__] out of here
with that but the fact that he had to
call a cab he did put kimchi in the bags
though yeah yeah hide the smell he
thought he was being like CL cuz kimchi
smells pretty bad I do not like you like
kimchi I I do not I right I don't I
don't really like it I got have a
Nostalgia for it yeah I get it like I
said we used to eat there was a
restaurant that we used to eat at
sometimes like called Korea House no
back near was it yeah it was called Kore
House near where we used to live Soul
something no it was called Korea House I
remember we used to go there we didn't
go there all the time but we went there
lots of times it's pretty good it was
pretty pretty good the BR GOI was good
but man they wanted to give you kimchi
with everything I'm just like nope it
was real Korean food it was yeah yeah
but um Koreans were eating in there they
owned it see that's how you know when
like a when like a restaurant is good
that's why like the Indian restaurant we
go to which is Fifth Element is like 80
90% go there Indians we'll be the only
white people in there we're yeah we're
pretty much it's us and like one other
and actually when we we went there last
weekend it was just us and like one
British couple yeah one white British
coule and then the rest of them were
idiots so I was like okay well the food
must be okay then but you know what I
mean it's a yeah it's pretty good
though um so yeah
so I can't get past that I can't get
past the fact that he [__] called the
cab with with body parts in garbage bags
that blows my [__] mind so
anyway um so later on like after he got
caught he actually said that he ate some
of his victim too like specifically
their
livers um but they were actually never
really able to confirm that so he might
have just been exaggerating maybe he got
the idea from Silence of the Lambs I
don't [__] know um they did say later
on which I'll get into but that he did
get some ideas from movies I don't know
if Silence of the lmbs is one of them
but maybe he got that whole I ate his
liver with a nice ke blahy blah so maybe
he was thinking about that but he did
say he would eat their livers and it uh
cleansed his Spirit that's what he would
say he was eating some of them um that's
what he said but I don't know yeah I the
cops kind of think that he was like
making that up bullsh like just to kind
of make himself seem more badass or
whatever trying to he's trying to
compete with some Western Syria killer
right that's what I'm saying or I said
he probably got the idea from Silence of
the lamp so uh so yeah so between May
and July of 2004 so yeah May June July
that's only three months he killed at
least nine women all of them uh Mass or
you know escorts that came from the
massage parlor uh all of them in their
20s one of them I believe was 33 but um
all the other ones were in their mid to
late 30s oh candy
thanks now here's the shitty thing and
um limle was saying this before that
it's like even though okay it has to be
said that at first they didn't initially
connect the rich people being bashed in
the with hamers crime with the sex
workers being killed crime you know what
I mean um because it's completely
different victim profile it was a
slightly different Mo in the sense that
you know the first one he was breaking
into people's houses and bashing them in
the head whereas this one he was calling
people to his house and have them
bashing them in the head but evident but
you know in the end they had to admit
that yeah this is probably the same dude
just because the wounds on the head like
the dents sadly in the people's heads
were EX exactly the same and it was like
such a
distinctive pattern like a distinctive
weapon that they figured okay well this
has got to be the same guy because you
have to think it was on they showed like
a map on the documentary like it's it
was across the river so it was like in
two I don't know how many miles there
were between the two areas where he was
killing but they didn't initially link
them and it was a different jurisdiction
that was another thing too is that you
know much like when you hear about
serial kill killer cases like in the
States from the 60s and 70s you hear
about this kind of inter departmental
it's like they didn't really communicate
with one another across jurisdiction so
it took a long time to kill to catch
zero Killers especially if they were
killing in lots of different cities or
lots of different areas because they
didn't communicate cuz why would they
like it wouldn't occur to them so kind
of the same thing was going on here
except it was the early 2000s so they
didn't initially link them but then
finally they uh they had
to now um so as it it turned out so the
cops were investigating they did
stakeouts they did all this other kind
of stuff but they really weren't getting
anywhere with anything but it turned out
what ended up happening and I think we
alluded to this
earlier was that um Yu young CH ended up
calling a massage parlor that he had
ordered girls from before but he called
it with a phone that belonged to a girl
that had gone missing cuz several you
know obviously a lot of the he called
from different massage parlors but they
did notice that some girls had gone
missing I don't think they were
initially all that alarmed because like
I said I think there's kind of a high
turnover in that uh line of work so
they're like oh well some of the girls
just take off or whatever so they
weren't really thinking too much about
it but the fact that this girl had been
gone and her phone was being used to
call this place again and the guy that
owned the brothel recognized the number
and he's like hey she's been missing for
a while so that's a little bit weird so
he decided to call the police now
initially they hadn't found any bodies
or anything like that so I think at
first they were thinking that maybe
someone was kidnapping these girls and
you know maybe selling them like into
sex labor or something like that so it's
like they weren't thinking murder at
first I don't think but they were just
thinking well obviously this dude is why
does he have this girl's phone so they
thought that was kind of strange so what
they decided to do was they said okay
we'll send somebody over now I don't
think this is interesting because I
don't think is that my nail that fell
off yeah okay yeah I don't think they
mentioned this on the documentary cuz
they they were trying to like make the
cops look a little bit better I guess
even though they were you know they did
admit that they'd [__] up but what
according to all the other sources that
I read what ended up happening was that
the owner of the massage parlor and a
bunch of the other employees of the
massage parlor
they decided we're going to figure out
what's going on we're going to get this
[__] they call the cops the
cops only sent one officer out at first
so they set up a date with Y young CH
who is called from this phone which
belongs to this woman who's missing and
they meet in this place now the first
young woman that they sent um he sent
her back because she was too tall like I
said he liked ones that were like really
short really little so they sent another
one now again again I don't think they
mentioned this in the documentary but
the one cop that was there left before
Yu young CH got there like to meet up
with the girl so when he got there the
actually the brothel owner and the other
employees like jumped on him and
restrained him until the cops could get
there that's how that went down I don't
think they said that on the documentary
but apparently that's how it really
happened so I I guess that was something
they didn't really want to that that it
was actually the brothel owner and the
employees that that kind of caught him
and then waited and then held him there
until the cops got
there so they finally uh they so they
arrested him and they take him into
custody now while he's in the
interrogation room he's kind of haming
and ha yeah maybe I killed these people
blahy blah um but then he F he faked an
epileptic seizure uh they said he
started like you know kind of
doing this and it's like his he was
foaming at the mouth and all this other
kind of stuff and in all of the uh
chaos he actually got away from them
like he escaped from the police station
and he didn't have any shoes on or
anything he was like he runs out his
[__] bare feet and nobody noticed and
there was even they showed on the
documentary they showed there was like
you know footage from inside the police
thing of him just like walking the [__]
out and I think somebody like even
walked like past him and we're just like
oh whatever baref put [__]
walking in the hall like they didn't
care about it so he what happened was is
he was foaming at the mouth for safety
reason they un they uncuffed him they
had him up on the side of the wall
sitting on a [__] One Cop left and then
a few minutes later the second cop
left and as he left he went out the
door the the killer went right out the
door with him right alongside him but he
didn't see it and he was turn yeah he he
went he was just like right and then
that guy
then the killer makes his way Outdoors
he passes a bunch of people just walks
out cop second cop comes back to um get
the killer secure him opens the door and
looks at where is that dude I thought he
was with you yeah it was that kind of
situation um this is yeah so they just
he he walked out and it was pouring rain
out he basically just walked out with no
shoes on so they put an APB they trying
to catch K they couldn't find it well
here's the thing and they and they
admitted this on the documentary they
admitted that they went to like the
prosecutor or like whoever I guess it
would be like the equivalent of The Da
maybe yeah and said can you sign a thing
that says we released him voluntarily
because we don't want it getting out
that he escaped from our custody because
at this point they didn't know he was
the Mur they were just holding him on
they're like well we could hold him on
theft cuz he obviously stole someone's
cell phone and it's like and we
suspected him for kidnapping is what
they were thinking because we they
didn't know where the girl was so um so
they didn't know like the full extent I
mean they suspected maybe this is the
[__] but they didn't know so
they're like but we still don't want the
public to know that he just [__]
walked out like they're already [__]
on us because of our incompetent police
work so they they did get the dude to
sign off he wasn't happy about it but he
did sign off on the [__] that said yeah
they released him voluntarily like to
save face you know here's the funny
thing the cops were [__] bricks they
were like where the [__] is this guy
they're looking for him yeah they were
freaking out you know where he went he
went home he just went home which that
would have been that should have been
the first place he his home because he
didn't have shoes he went back to his
house and like in his mom and his sister
or somebody like that then they helped
him pack up and get the [__] out he even
got rid of some of his murder weapon and
did all kinds of stuff and just [__]
got [__] out of there they knew who he
was they knew where he lived I would
have gone right to his house he was
there yeah I don't know how long he was
there but that was the first place he
went the first place I would have gone
as well yeah obviously undercover guys
CU he needs his [__] right he needs his
[__] and he probably needs to like clean
up evidence and Sh imag at least need
some shoes right before he can go on the
run I mean that's the first place you'd
go go home I'm not even a cop and I know
that he'd go home but they weren't they
were Pro maybe they were thinking well
he's too sophisticated to go home he
won't go back home he's not that dumb
yeah he is no people are practical they
need to go home and get some stuff and
like I said he might have needed to get
rid of evidence so he wouldn't get his
ass in trouble yeah but he did go home
but I don't know how long he was there
and then he went someplace else and the
weird thing about that now he was only
they did I don't know if they really
said how long he was only um escaped for
12 hours um you know which you know
that's a long time but they they caught
him after 12 hours but the weird thing
about it is that they seem to have
caught him they said it was pretty much
pure luck um they said one of the
detectives just had an inkling that he
would go to this particular area they
had cops everywhere Tammy said yeah you
had to get a special Hammer yeah exactly
yeah that's what I mean
so so I I don't know why they wouldn't
have just gone there like immediately
that seems like the first place that I
would have gone but you
know yeah DVD Dragon says serial killer
using Uber to transport body parts
suitcase is smelling like a bag full of
[__] yeah that's what I mean it's
just like that I don't know that's like
it's horrible but it's also kind of like
Darkly funny to me like that whole
scenario where a serial killer would
have to like didn't have a car and would
have to like use public transportation
how you get rid of the bodies and stuff
yeah it's just sounds crazy but one one
of the thing I think one of the reasons
why there are so many serial killers in
the United States the United States is
[__] famous for them is because
freedom of movement in the United States
well everybody has cars and the
motherfucker's big it's big there's a
lot of rural areas uh it's uncontrolled
you can drive from one state to the
other without having to ask permission
you couldn't do that in the Soviet Union
Soviet Union you couldn't even leave
your town without special papers you
have permission because everybody lived
at where their work assignment was and
they had to be assigned to go to work
every day they control where you where
you live and your movement you to get
permission to take off from work to go
to these places usually during your
vacation
time they had serial killers in the
Soviet Union but it's controll Network
prevented the people didn't have [__]
cars you'd have to take the body along
the damn train you know that hi don't
mind yeah so America allowed it the
situation in the United States allowed
for serial killer
Behavior freedom of
movement yeah and like you're in your
car by yourself nobody knows what the
[__] you're up to you could have all
kind of like dead hookers in your trunk
and no one would know the more free and
open a society is the more crime you can
commit and get away with I'm eating a
Three Musketeers yeah that's what it is
some it's our leftover Halloween cany
yeah Halloween cany we had a bunch left
over yeah we didn't have that many kids
but yeah let me finish chewing it keep
talking but um but you know a free and
open Society has a lot
of you know you want it but you have to
pay for it and um the price is is you
can have people that abuse it you know
this not as many as you might think but
but yeah abusing it well yeah because
any any place where you can be like hey
I'm going to you know wake up tomorrow
and drive 3,000 Mi to Oregon and you
know kill some lot lizards on my way and
just dump them in the Texas Killing
Fields or whatever it's like they would
never they never catch those people they
just don't how could they place like
Korea where your
average poor guy would never be able to
really afford a car they just use public
transportation that right there keeps
from being the kind of serial killer
you'd find in the United States that'll
transport bodies all around well it's
probably why they caught this
[__] after only 10 months
instead of like I said here there's some
he been gone for a long time well here
there's unsolved murders from like the
70s like I said like that you know there
was like a girl that was a run away she
got picked up by a trucker or something
and like they she got dumbed somewhere
and they never found her yeah you know
it's sad but it happens like all the
[__] time like I said it's a massive
[__] place and it's just kind of like
a huge Road system yeah that too like
Russia is huge but it doesn't really
have a vast Road system so you can't go
everywhere most of it's uh built around
a train
system so even though it's physically
big you can't access most of
it the United States you can access
almost every nook and cranny there's
roads
Everywhere You can't shut anything off
everything's all
interconnected so that's true it's a and
cars cheap available cars
everywhere so it's a Serial Killer's
dream yeah pretty much yeah you don't
got to take public transportation most
of the time
yeah that's the loser serial killer
that's
loser man I got to take the [__] sun
rail yeah and you're not going to find
serial killers like this in New York
City though either true Boston it's you
know same thing public transportation
yeah committing there's crimes there
they're just not committing this kind of
crime right I mean to be honest you
could probably kill somebody and have a
dead body sitting next to you like on
the New York subway in the middle of the
night and probably no one would
notice Boston Strangler killed a bunch
of women but he killed them and left
them where they were right what I mean
it still happens they just do it in a
different different way way like when
there's
um you know when there's ample place to
like bury the bodies and you think
they're not going to be found then
obviously they're going to like take
them out there and do it but otherwise
they're just going to leave them serial
killer archetype modern serial killer
archetype would be Ted budy he drove a
lot yeah he had a VW Bug well and he
killed people in several different
states too which again is why it took so
long to catch him and we've talked about
that before the reason why it takes so
long to catch particular kinds is
they're targeting people that are not
related to them and a lot of times
they're driving across the country or
something like that somebody's
hitchhiking they pick him up they kill
him they dump him in another state and
if that girl is as strange from her
family or or whatever it's like she
might not ever be reported missing and
then they'll find her bones like 30
years later and they don't know who it
is which is like really sad but they do
really seem to be trying to
identify um a lot of those cases because
a lot of the cases that I wrote about in
my faceless villain series that were
just like um Jane do or John do I've
noticed like I when I went back cuz I've
been writing like updates um for my
crime in Memorial site and a lot of them
they've identified who they were like
they haven't figured out who killed them
yet but at least they know who they are
now so they are like trying to go
through these backlogs and like trying
to do DNA and like trying to figure out
who they are at least yeah to like help
them like so they are still working on
it which is nice Miss Lee was in here
earlier one of the things she said is
that he was targeting prostitutes in
Korea she's Korean if you guys missed
the beginning of the show so they were
targeting she he was targeting
prostitutes because nobody cared about
him that's kind of a Mis interpretation
of what's
happening they target prostitutes
because they're e they have easy access
to them and it's harder to get caught if
you kill them because it's harder to
track down who that girl was with and
where she was they live a little bit
more of a their motions their movements
through Society are a little secret and
they're confusing she might have been
with six guys that night it's hard to I
isolate exactly which
one and they may not have much contact
with their family so they when they go
missing the family doesn't know that
they're missing
yeah so the the police are not alerted
it's not that the F her family doesn't
care about her that her family doesn't
know that she's missing yeah that
happens a lot and then cuz they're kind
of arranged like I said or it's like oh
well she's off doing her own thing and
they don't really approve or she doesn't
talk to them anymore or something and
The Pimps know that they're missing but
they don't know why they're missing did
they did she just run and go back
home should he call the police well if
he calls the police he has to explain
how he knows her and what his connection
is right so then he's like he'll get in
trouble she maybe she just went back
home or maybe she's working for another
pip now so it's not like nobody cares
about him it's just harder for the
police to be alerted to the situation
because of the situation because it's
such a legally gray yeah profession
right in a lot of situations so a lot of
people aren't going to and I think that
they kind of even brought that that up a
little bit like in this documentary
where they were talking about well a lot
of the brothel owners even if they
noticed that some of the women went
missing they didn't report it because
it's like well we didn't want to get in
trouble or we didn't want anybody
cracking down on our operation and just
because they went missing doesn't mean
that they were dead they didn't assume
that like I said there was a high
turnover so they didn't immediately
assume and it's Korea so they didn't
immediately assume murder because it
didn't happen that often they're
assuming that she quit went back home or
that she [__] quit and is working for
another brool or another pet now or
something she got a better off they
weren't like alarm or she hooked up with
one of her clients and now she's living
with him and she's no longer a proess I
mean the only reason that one dude
became alarmed was because of the phone
number the phone call came back she's
like man it's that girl that's that
girl's phone and this dude is calling
from her phone and that's weird so it's
not like they don't care about him even
in you know Korea they cared about him
if you killed one of them you could get
a life sentence or a death sentence for
killing one of them they cared about
just that they didn't know yeah it's
hidden so that's a a healthier way of
looking at it and that's the same thing
here in the United States if you go out
and you go killed them prostitutes you
going to go to jail if they catch you or
they going to if you or execute you they
care just that it's harder to get caught
that's it is harder to get that's why
they target they target them Bryce says
a lot of prostitutes use fake names too
yeah that's true not even not even their
pimps or madams know their actual name
at least here in New Zealand they move
around a lot too yeah that's what I mean
so I kind of feel like and especially in
the' 60s and70s that was very big in the
US where serial killers would Target not
only sex workers but also like runaways
or people who were hitchhiking or
something like that because like I said
you could pick somebody up in Florida
and then drive to [__] Minnesota and
kill them and dump them somewhere and
then drive to [__] Washington State
and no one would there was no connection
yeah they wouldn't know who that girl's
name was the people that hired her
wouldn't know what her real name was
like you said they wouldn't know who the
parents were parents weren didn't even
know where she was yeah she wasn't from
there they didn't they didn't know where
she was so she's basically a transient
right you know and transient people are
you could easily it's you could get away
with them nobody around there knows who
that person is they're easy target sadly
right yeah it's [__] up and like I
said and I think that's specifically why
yeah he targeted specifically why modern
providers or prostitutes that are
working online demand so much ID before
they go see you and face to face over
and everybody knows where she's going
and she's got she's got proof and and
here in the United
States if you assault one of them girls
she will go to the cops she knows your
your name she doesn't care cuz then
she's not going to do any time for that
you are though yeah well hope they're
not do anything to her the law is not
going to do anything to her oh well yeah
he he raped you nearly killed you but
[__] you're a prostitute you got to go
to jail no they're not going to do that
they're going to go after that dude well
yeah because it's a case of wellme which
is the greater crime here obviously
right you know I mean like I said
there's [__] up situations where you
know that didn't happen but in general
that's usually how it goes that's how it
goes now yeah
yeah um okay so so he so he escaped like
I said he was escaped for about 12 hours
he did go back to his house briefly to
get his [__] and then like he went
someplace else now interestingly one of
the detectives said that he just had a
feeling that we need to go to this
particular town or this particular area
and they so they put a bunch of cops
there and it so happened and it's like
the middle of the day and it's like this
was [__] crazy it was almost kind of
like like a miracle or something like
that but one of the cops spotted him
just like crossing the [__] Street
like at the crosswalk walking around
like in the middle of the day yeah um
and they were like it it was just like
pure [__] chance that they were there
and that they saw him crossing the
street and they were like [__]
Hallelujah because they were flipping
out for 12 hours they were like oh my
God I can't believe we lost him and
we're just going to have to like fake it
like we didn't lose him like we let him
go on purpose but they got him back like
after 12 hours and he didn't kill
anybody in those 12 hours thankfully he
said R said here in New Zealand The
Pimps are very protected well they have
to be yeah they got to watch out for
their own man those girls are vulnerable
you just got to know who she's with
where she's going you probably want
somebody waiting on her you know outside
they got have security bcer I mean I
would have a whole like [__]
Entourage system going on here according
to the advice that I've heard is that
the girls [__] they're trying to
build regulars they know the guy they've
worked with him regularly but they still
know who he is and she's with him that's
I would want to have like some dirt on
them I want to know where they [__]
live I want to know you know what I mean
they have they have a copy of his ID
that's what I'm saying you know what he
is I want to know all that kind of [__]
you can blank out your Social Security
your social security number on it or
whatever your driver's license number
they just want to know what your name is
and what you look like they can find you
that way yeah yeah as long as I the
people can find you after in case you
kill my ass so just go to the police and
say that's the dude she was with yeah
your ass is over and then you're done
yeah so yeah so they catch this dude
after 12 hours and they bring him back
in and at this
point um he actually they brought him in
and he really didn't seem shy at all uh
he seemed kind of proud of it he
initially confessed to killing 19
people uh and then later on confessed to
a few more I think um the confession
rate that he came up with I think that
he said that he killed 26 people like
and this was a couple days after he was
arrested now in the documentary one of
the detectives said that when they had
brought him in like they had this um
like all this paper like on a clipboard
or something and they said he picked up
a pen and started making like hatch
marks like on the
paper and um they were like well what is
that and he's like this is all the
people that I've killed and I think he
said there were 30 hatch marks on there
which is possible cuz like I said he did
confess to 26 he only got convicted of
20 but there were probably some more
because as it was he confessed to or he
lost count maybe like he confessed to
like the sex worker murders but then
like later on he said oh yeah I also
killed that guy like in the van that you
know he set the van on fire and all that
like he confessed to that later on and
he did confess to at least one that
ended up being another serial killer but
I don't really see they know that he
killed at least 20 so I don't really see
any reason for him to exaggerate it any
more than that although he did take
credit for one that he didn't do but
that's about it maybe he trying to get
that guy off maybe maybe he was like hey
I like that dude I'm just gonna although
that that guy got caught too or he just
he killed 14 people I think that other
guy that he just said ah [__] it I'm I'm
going to take credit for that one yeah
cuz that was just I think she was just
walking down the street and she got
stabbed that's the one that he got
stabbed she got stabbed but he didn't do
it it was it was a it was a different
serial killer no he did stab um a couple
of the victims oh he did but um mostly
it was bludgeoning that that was kind of
his thing I think he mostly just use
knives like to cut them up afterward but
I think he did 30 nearly 30 is quite a
bit maybe he his memory was a little bit
hazy yeah that's what I mean and or
maybe he killed some but like I said he
he seemed kind of proud of it so I don't
may have not been able to keep them all
straight maybe not so um so yeah he he
didn't seem shy about it he just uh
confessed all his yeah I killed all
these people and so they asked him it's
like well um can you show us where all
the bodies are that uh what let do in
DVD Dragon oh A Pimp's love is very
different from that of a square yeah
right out of Idiocracy you see A Pimp's
love is a very different kind of love
that from Square yeah that movie was
great
man yeah Tom that he put the fake teeth
in and he [__] the army guy is like
the army officer funny
yeah so um
so yeah uh I okay so he said that he
would lead them to the bodies of the I
mean obviously they had the bodies for
the the older people cuz they just left
him in the house but all the sex workers
that he had killed so he led them out
there well the weird thing about it was
that there okay at
first cuz remember the cops were saying
this at first they thought maybe he was
just a crazy person that he was just
like one of those people that just like
confessed to [__] and he didn't do
anything
and so they took him out to some of the
houses like of the quote unquote rich
people murders and they said at first he
went to the wrong house and he gave them
details like oh this victim was like um
like face up like face up when actually
she was face down [__] like that and so
some of the cops were like oh maybe it's
not him because he's giving us like all
these wrong details but the main
detective guy was like no I'm pretty
sure this is the [__] here
because he's and he thought that he was
just like with them and then like later
on I think this was actually before the
Escape but then like after he escaped
and he came back and then he was like
yeah I did all that [__] and then they
asked him like about the rich people
murders and they said he drew maps of
the or you know uh layouts of the houses
like the way the bodies were and
everything like that and he knew like
everything down to every [__] detail
and he got everything correct so there's
like there's no way that anybody but the
killer would have known that [__] you
know what I mean yeah so they're like
okay we're pretty pretty sure it's him
now and then when they said okay we'll
take us to where you buried the bodies
and he went right to the place and he
was just kind of like with his little
bottle caps and he's just like and they
started digging the bodies up and he's
just like oh yeah that's so and so and I
killed her on this date like on this day
or whatever and he knew every single
thing like what he had done to them he
killed them all in like a pretty similar
way like I said but he remembered like
every detail about it which a lot of
serial killers do because they store it
like so they can fantasize about it
later on so they were like yeah he just
stood there and very casually just like
yeah I killed that girl like this on
this date and blahy blah and they were
like freaking out about it so yeah when
they dug up all the bodies um they
actually found 11 uh bodies in this this
burial thing obviously he killed at
least 20 people but those were the 11 of
the sex workers that he had killed and
buried there now they also searched his
apartment uh which was you know after he
was arrested and they thought that
maybe he had patterned some of his
killings after some movies that he had
because in the drawer of his computer
desk he had some DVDs or whatever of
some movies now one of these was a movie
called Public Enemy which was a Korean
movie from 2002 and this was about like
a like a rogue cop and a psychopath kind
of pitted against one another so there
was that he also had a copy of a movie
which I've seen actually called very bad
things which is uh from 1998 it's a
black com
uh and there is a scene in that which
like guys at a bachelor party like
accidentally kill a stripper and then
decide they're going to cut her up and
like bury her in the desert uh so
there's that and then there was also a
movie that he had called normal life
which is from 1996 and that's an
American movie based on uh the lives of
husband and wife bank robbers Jeffrey
and Jill Erikson so he was a great
admirer of these kind of like crime kind
of movies movies so they thought that
some of the crimes were patterned after
some of the [__] that was in these
movies um he also as I I think I
mentioned this earlier he was really
into this other serial killer uh Jong du
Yong um who was another one that killed
wealthy people like between 1998 and 20
1999 and 2000 like he killed some of
them and he was kind of patterning
himself after that as well because that
was his mentor or his that's who he
looked up to I guess which is kind of
messed up that's weird so there was a
whole there was a Spate of God of Korean
serial killers that targeted rich people
well just the two of them just that just
those two but they were rare Ser killers
were rare yeah and it was kind of around
the same time well this well this guy
was a little bit earlier but it's weird
because in American Western culture
sirak killery is always a sexual motive
almost always oh yeah yeah pretty much
that's always if not then it's a it's a
mass murderer and it's not quite the
same thing Tammy's like Pooky I know
yeah that's Pooky poy she's like hey
Pooky she's being cute and everything
this cat's getting heavy oh she's like
running
wheel like a hamster wheel get her a
little workout there yeah I already told
her I was going to get her a little
Richard Simmons outfit and some little
like getting heav dumbbells
yeah she's not that heavy she's having
fun though yeah and fun eating all that
food huh she's like yeah I'm a cat I can
just do whatever I want I don't have to
be r looking at this looking at the fan
yeah she she doesn't like that fan she
loves fan she doesn't like that
fan she keeps looking at that it's like
she every time I turn that fan on she
looks like super offended yeah she just
GNA fall well it it might I you know I I
can't can't blame her for that I don't
really like it being on either but it's
[__] hot in here another thing too is
that when they went and searched his
apartment and I think you mentioned this
earlier they said they they went in
there and it looked like oh my God he's
a [__] neat freak they're like
everything was like
spotless you know and so I was like well
obviously he killed at least like 9 10
11 women in there so yeah he's going to
clean the [__] out of it but I guess he
didn't know about
luminol so again not real not real smart
on the criminal thing it's like haven't
you [__] seen CSI did they have CSI
back in the 2004 maybe not uh all CS
well didn't they have like True Crime
shows and [__] like that I thought
everybody knew about luminol you can
clean the blood off all you want they
spray Lum all that [__] they can still
see all of it and they said they went in
the bathroom and spray and it looked
super clean and they sprayed luminol and
it like there was just Fu blood
everywhere it was just like everywhere
they like it was all over the ceiling it
was all over the walls it was just all
over the [__] place so it's not as
clean as you think it is but yeah picks
up jizz too I think it does yeah it does
well yeah that's why um if you watch
another dirty room Dan Bell's show like
a lot of times they have like the the
Lum all the black light and they try to
like they'll spray it on the on the
hotel comforters [__] horrifying it was
like up on the walls like underneath the
like underneath the desk there was one
that was like underneath the desk and it
was just like Cascades of it like and he
was like oh it's like what like somebody
just like sat there and did it like
again and again I guess this messed up
you had never you would never sleep in a
hotel ever again if you saw that [__]
that's I try not to think about it but
you know um so yeah uh also there was an
incident and they went into this on the
documentary as well where the mother of
one of the victims uh and they showed
the footage of this she ran at him
because they were brought they were
bringing him out to I they were taken to
the prosecutor or something like that so
they were like transferring him from
building to building um you know after
they caught him and one of the victim's
mothers ran up at him with an umbrella
like she was going to stab him or
something and one of the cops who was
holding uh Y young CH kicked her and she
went tumbling down the [__] Stone
stairs this older she wasn't old but she
was like an older lady like tumbling
down the stairs yeah like a middle-aged
lady they didn't realize I guess who it
was at first but I mean still not a
great look yeah but like when they had
the cop on that did that when everybody
yeah when everybody knew about it later
they were just kind of like they a bunch
of them got like demoted and like [__]
like that because it's like like I said
that was one of the cuz she even said
like after she fell and stuff like that
she's like if you would like she said
something like if you had acted sooner
like my daughter would still be alive or
something like that which is [__] up
yeah they kind of lost their cool they
did they did but they [__] he didn't
mean it I guess he just saw somebody
coming at him and like and he just like
reacted without thinking about it but if
you see the footage it looks bad I mean
it's like this is little middle AG lady
and here's this cop like just kicking
her down the [__] and she goes
tumbling down the [__] stairs and I'm
just like great here here's the thing
that's looking funny earlier on I was
talking when uh when Miss Lee was here I
was saying that Koreans are kind of milk
toast they're not real violent but
there's there's some caveats to
this I think because this the the uh the
society is pretty kind of like
emotionally kind of a little bit uptight
they kind of kind of guarded they're I
could say you call them conservative in
a way they
don't they don't get real expressive
they try to keep the emotions
down because of that when they get
pissed sometimes they get [__] they
get hilarious
they because they're so [__] they're
so pent up because they're kind of pent
up they [__] lose it it becomes like
nerd rage though you know it's what we
call nerd ra so I saw the video of the
cop kicking the old lady that's kind of
what it looked like nerd rage is because
they they got a accused of they're being
accused of being incompetent but they
have been working they were [__]
working all [__] day and night
sleeping in those offices and [__] they
weren't even going home and a dude just
lost it and she physically came forward
he just it was an instant [__]
retaliation thing he he think about it
you know and he didn't kick her that
hard it was just he knocked her back
with his foot I think it'd be a better
way to [__] describe it she went
flying you know she wasn't a real
physical physically mighty person of
course but it was like I could see in
his face that Korean nerd rage man
[__] that sometimes would happen with
kusas we were working with you know
Korean soldiers were working they
[__] lose it it's kind of [__]
funny they don't quite get mad the way a
Westerner does you know what I mean they
don't they don't just let it out but
they go they go over the top man they go
over the top you know like remember the
dude [__] attacking the front of the
the van yeah front of the van and was
like the victim brother yeah Koreans
when they get emotional man they [__]
get melodramatic man
real [__] um emo real emo real
emotional it just comes out you know
North Koreans even more been look at
when Kim Kim Kim Jong Il
died they got out there pretending to
cry as hard as they can well you know
they're they're like that Koreans are
kind of softies they kind of
soft-hearted you know uh but it's just
funny
man this culture is different than ours
but you know each each little culture
has its own thing yeah that's that's
okay yeah I'm just saying it didn't look
great um to get to get that on camera
like a cop kicking a middle-aged yeah
well they thought about victim mother
didn't look too good down the steps well
yeah so a lot of cops did get in trouble
yeah and like the main detective
actually he got demoted and he was on
there and he was just like I can't
believe I that's ridiculous I can't
believe that happened to me cuz he he
didn't do it but he was held responsible
cuz he was in charge you know what I
mean yeah cuz they were like man already
like the media is like [__] tearing
you new [__] because you [__] up
the investigation and let the dude
Escape which they tried to cover that up
but everyone kind of found out about it
anyway yeah so they so they weren't
looking too good so everybody was just
kind of like why like all these people
are dying and you're not doing anything
so you know they they were under a lot
of stress I get that but yeah they did
kind of whiff it and they and they
admitted that as much and like I said
it's better now than it used to be so um
so at this stage they're like okay they
had to admit they didn't have a [__] ton
of physical evidence like obviously they
have a lot of kind of like I what you
would call like circumstantial evidence
yeah they got like the matching shoe
prints from all the rich people murders
like three or four of those crime scenes
that was the same shoeprint um they had
the fact that uh Y young ch um you know
Drew Maps or Drew um charts of like what
the insides of the crime scenes looked
like and he got all that correct he
obviously LED them exactly to where all
the bodies were and knew where all knew
who all of them were and stuff like that
so that's good but they're like we
wanted something that was like
definitive we wanted like some DNA
evidence so they did eventually end up
finding the murder weapon they did end
up finding his hammer like when they
were searching through all of his stuff
now the hammer had been very very
thoroughly washed so on the outside of
it they didn't find any DNA evidence and
they were kind of bummed out about that
however they got like the forensic team
in there and the forensic team pulled it
apart like they pulled the head off of
the handle and they said when we scraped
around the inside of the hole like where
the um where the handle went and like on
the end of the handle they found DNA
from several of the victims which was
still in there in the Korean um program
that we really recommend what's the name
of it again it's just called um the
raincoat killer the r Co killer it's on
it's on
Netflix they had a Korean prosecutor on
there and uh he brings up you could tell
he's uh he's now into serial killers and
he uh you know kind of studied the
Western history of serial killers and
the forensics and everything what what
the trials are like and he's of course
preparing for trial on this guy and he
tells a story there he says uh you know
all the police and everybody is saiding
oh we got him he confessed and he says
no that's not enough confessions are you
have to have physical evidence people
confess to [__] all the time that they
didn't do he says I want this D
basically he's like I want this dude
locked up and he talked about you know
the West's experience with this thing he
said he he he said he he wanted to find
DNA evidence on that [__] hammer and
eventually they did but not on the
outside it's on the inside yeah they had
to pull it apart they pulled it apart
and there was some DNA evidence and got
them and I think it was more than one
person's DNA in there they found several
of the victim's DNA that way you
can you can prove that there's a
physical length between him that hammer
and those dead victims yeah and there's
no way to deny it right so he can't come
out and go well I just made all that
[__] up because you at least got him on
these three how do you explain them damn
three different DNA profiles how they
end up on your Hammer right those people
are all there's really no way to there's
no way so that was that's what sealed
his and they really really wanted to get
that and they were afraid that they
wouldn't because like said the
outside um didn't have any cuz it had
been pretty thoroughly washed he had
thoroughly washed everything yeah but he
didn't think to take it apart and big
difference between in the program you'll
see there's a big difference between the
Korean the attitudes of the Korean cops
at and the detectives at at the time and
the
prosecutors prosecutors are sounding
more Western a lot more modern all right
you got to have [__] modern forensic
proof the cops the Korean cops at this
time sound more like American detectives
of the [__] 50s yeah kind of behind
the times it's like well he confess we
got him he confess we got him I'm like
no court of law doesn't work that way it
doesn't stand up really you got to have
other [__] might take him 10 20 years
but that dude eventually might fight his
way legally out of that manam prison
cell you got to seal his fate man you
got to have physical evidence proof they
got it eventually they did yeah so they
were very excited when they got the DNA
evidence like of several of the victims
inside of the
hammer
so as far as as far as Yu young CH goes
he did say and I don't believe this for
one second he did say that he was sorry
for what he did um however he also said
that if he had not been caught he would
not have stopped killing um that he
would have just kept going cuz why not I
guess uh yeah he said I had no intention
of stopping the killing that's what he
said now they had a
psychologist um you know examine him the
psychologist said uh he's not mentally
ill just in in the sense that he
obviously knew right from wrong but he
had uh antisocial personality disorder
yeah uh in the sense that he was
creating his own belief system yeah
based on distrust of moral and social
norms yeah so he's like in living in his
own little
he takes that and then he twists himself
into deeper and deeper into
damn Insanity I'm going to call it
Insanity yeah you know just in in
layman's terms it's not technically
Insanity because he did know what he was
doing was bad I'm going to use a better
word he twists himself more and more
into evil what he's doing yeah yeah
although he sees himself as good or he
was saying he was Godlike now you're
more like Devil like more like the devil
GRE pictures of him and the devil yeah
so I think he knew he was just lying to
people well but you know he was trying
to come across as like he had a
righteous cause yeah no kind of I think
that was that's what he wanted to be
seen as he was telling them but I think
deep down he knew that he was the devil
yeah he was punishing them in a
devil-like way like that they you know
they belong in hell and they're going to
come with me that type of he's the devil
too interestingly several of the
detectives called him that too the devil
yeah that he was like the devil cuz they
had never seen anything like that yeah
like even they were saying that even
before they caught him like when they
went to the crime scenes they were like
a devil did this yeah cuz they couldn't
imagine America seemed much worse well
yeah yeah but I'm just saying closer to
the devil he is one of the children of
the devil
definitely he is one of the devil's
children but he's not the devil they get
worse than that yeah that's if you can
believe it but yeah um this is [__] up
they and I kind of had this mentioned in
my notes and they mentioned this in the
the documentary as well he said that um
he wasn't he didn't seem bothered at all
um he didn't have any remorse for what
he had done he said that the only time
during this whole spree that he actually
felt afraid or felt fear was that when
he was in the course of mutilating one
of his victims one of the sex workers
his son called him in the middle of it
and he had to like talk to his son on
the
phone and his son was like asking him
normal ass questions like oh hey Dad you
sound funny do you still have a cold and
stuff like that and he said that kind of
weirded him out but it's just kind of
like what was he doing cutting her up he
was cutting up a he was cutting up a
woman okay yeah can you imagine like
you're cutting up a woman and then your
son calls Hey Dad how are you doing he
was like his son was like 11 or
something yeah and that didn't like give
him pause I well I guess it did but not
enough to make him [__] stop doing it
did
it I don't think he was as
compartmentalized as [__] as Dennis
Raider yeah Dennis Raider he had
everything in little
compartments so I think he was just you
know it was all just one form he just
realized Cub probably was just thinking
about how bad he
was yeah I mean that's [__] up that's
[__] up he's doing this it's not
giving him any relief it's not making
him any better he's probably getting
worse well yeah because it did seem like
well and this happens in a lot of serial
killer cases but the [__] was like
escalating in the sense that it was
getting closer and closer together it
was just over such a short period
because like I said a lot of serial
killers will go on for years and years
but this was only like 10 months so it
was more like a spree they have these
inner drives these inner desires and
then they try to satisfy them but they
never get satisfied becomes Hollow so
they they try to escalate the the amount
of people that they're going to kill
yeah because they think oh well I just
need that more that bigger hit yeah of
whatever but yeah although I I sense
there's
something weak about
him he couldn't like he couldn't face
these girls he crept up behind them and
hit him in the back of the head with a
hammer yeah he didn't keep them around
and talk to them and torture him or
anything it it's like
shame yeah you know what I'm talking
about
yeah so all that all that boasting and
all that bragging he's trying to
compensate for shame I
think probably because the real bad ones
will keep that woman around sometimes
days yeah and do all kind of horrible
[__]
yeah they're gloating over you know it's
likeing so he's not as bad as he thinks
he is he's bad but he's not as bad as he
thinks he is he's hiding from them girls
yeah he's creeping up behind
pow and then that's it and then he cut
she didn't even know yeah she didn't
even know what happened probably I mean
I hope she how much TR to bet those
girls didn't even know what happened I
hope they didn't n probably because
that's a blunt force trauma to the Head
it just [__] they just saw Stars if
they didn't kill her instantly he just
hit her a couple more times they didn't
even know what happened
probably yeah he did arm was raised he
did all the mutilation like after died
you know
which I don't know it's it's [__] up
but like I said we've covered a lot more
[__] up ones than this but yeah I
don't know I hate to put it on the
spectrum because it's all bad I'm just
you know what I mean but yeah so um he's
a coward yeah he's a coward yeah I mean
he got okay so he got convicted of 20
murders and he was given the death
penalty but because uh in Korea the
death penalty has been it's still legal
but it's on it's been on hold or like on
a moratorium since 1997 so there's a lot
of people on death row he's still on
death row so he's still alive but he's
still on there so his case in particular
has kind of like spurred a lot of debate
about the death penalty in Korea as far
as I'm aware but it also did um as I
said a lot of good in the way that they
investigate crimes of this nature which
they weren't really they weren't used to
it prepared for like prior to this
happen like I said not their fault it
just didn't happen um in the same some
things were their fault yeah yeah I'm
not letting them off the hook entirely
because they did [__] up a lot because
they knew a serial killer was out there
and they didn't want to say that no no
no no we're no no no it's not a serial
killer oh no yeah they kind of wanted to
pretend that no a serial kill they
wanted to say that they were like
unrelated crimes make they did not want
to face the truth yeah and they knew
what the truth was but they didn't want
to face they went into denial yeah you
know so that's on them that's
now they couldn't have prevented
anything by accepting it but they would
have gotten their [__] together and
started to investigate when they Adit
they should have admitted to themselves
yeah this is this is probably a seral
killer yeah we need to train that would
have got the ball rolling a little bit
sooner yeah I don't know if it would
have actually saved anybody's lives but
yeah it's you know it's hard to tell you
can't really go back in time and run
that experiment it's just that it's kind
of does not look good on on on the
Korean police of that day that they were
reluctant to admit that it was a serial
killer that's that's a yeah and I mean
if it had been like my relative that was
killed yeah I'd be pissed yeah you know
and yeah maybe if they had like got
their heads out of their asses quicker
like maybe it would have saved her maybe
it wouldn't have but it's just kind of
like the thought the the possibility
that it might have would be enough to
like piss you off yeah maybe they would
have got her got him a couple victims
early words you know might have saved a
couple right but he would have still
killed a lot of them yeah but still
that's one or two people yeah that's
that are dead that would have been alive
you know what I mean so any that would
anything would have been better yeah but
so they actually uh they did make a
movie about this case in 2008 in Korea
which was called the Chaser and uh as we
mentioned it's also a documentary it's
on Netflix uh which came out in 2021
called the raincoat killer chasing a
predator in Korea um it's three episodes
it's actually really good like I said
it's mostly focused on the investigation
of the crime not so much the killer
himself and um they also they went into
this a little bit on the documentary
they were saying that maybe I think we
kind of alluded to this earlier but
prior to the crime starting and
considering Yu young ch's uh motive of
you know growing up in poverty and being
resentful of rich people um there was
kind of like an economic
crisis um around this time where you
know the the wealth disparity got got
like much much worse and there was a lot
of poverty and they didn't really have
the I guess um they hadn't really been
anything through anything like this
before so it was like very there was a
lot of uh cultural upheaval so they were
kind of like blaming that a little bit
on maybe that's why he lashed out at
that particular time you know but it was
kind of interesting how they went into
the background because I wasn't really
aware that that had happened in Korea
around that time period cuz I don't know
that seems like it's always going on
here but you know but it was going on
there like uh to a great degree there
still kind of making movies about that
nowadays you know like parasite and
Squid game like the show that's on
Netflix is kind of like uh kind of goes
into that too Koreans make some good
movies now at least the best movies are
good movies I don't seen them all but a
lot of the movies that make it here
they're popular like like like you said
squid game and fing parasite uh train
TOS on they're good yeah this uh Netflix
series is real good you guys would like
it yeah yeah it's got
subtitles well yeah obviously yeah but
it it shot
well yeah and you know a lot of it is
just kind of like the investigators
talking about the cases but still
they're interesting characters yeah I
thought they were everybody in it's
interesting yeah I thought they were
they show a lot of good scenes from
Soul that Tom remembers from back in his
old days back in the day of banging
hookers look at that [__] in Korea
yeah there's another
era there's another
era there was a whole Army of American
servicemen there I to tease you about it
to protect that to help protect that
[__] country at least in politically
you know to back them up then then the
the Korean government sent an entire
Army of [__] well-trained Korean
pretty girls to get every bit of money
out of your pocket and get that into the
into the Korean
economy yeah it was fun man
Donan Tom had a good time yeah yeah
everybody had a good time we were
talking about maybe he had fathered some
children that he didn't know about it's
possibility it's possibility we were
talking about that the other day
anything's possible when
you're anything's
possible Jenny fantasized about that
proba Bo he's probably got children
running around I don't know I don't
know anything's possible it is yeah
that's what I'm saying you and you and
your yeah wild ass dick stop it
it slinging it around look it was normal
it was normal it was I'm just [__] it
was very early
90s was part of the army scene uh it was
just an accepted thing that was going on
there were like little military
recreational areas it was just guys from
the Army and these clubs that was just
packed F of these Club girls and they
were having fun we were having fun you
know just I don't know where those girls
came from or what the situation was they
all seemed normal to me they all seem
like they're having a good time so I
don't know he wasn't worried about it
no no they were just you know they were
they were our age most of them were you
know early
20s cute cute they lived in nice rooms
and [__] you know although you were
saying that when they showed the stuff
on the document here about um the way
the the massage P yeah like you said it
didn't quite look the same no now they
have them all like sitting in the front
windows like in Amsterdam yeah they have
sitting front windows like an AM
Amsterdam and when when I was there in
the early 90s they didn't have anything
like that hooker Hill was just look like
a bunch of bars and clubs yeah well
technically it's still illegal right I
don't think it was illegal then H I
think it was legal
then cuz what they were talking about
and this might have been because you
were there in the 90s and this was
taking place in the early 2000s cuz they
were saying on the documentary that it's
like well prostitution was illegal but
it was still everywhere it was rampant
yeah um and usually the brothel owners
just like paid bribes like to the cops
like to keep to keep their [__] open
yeah and like some of them were ex cops
so there was like a lot of corruption
and stuff so I don't really know if it
was legal back then and they just kind
of turned a blind ey to it or in the
early 990s when I was there I believe it
was legal because the Army knew all
about it the Army was Medics down in
there to make sure everybody was good
they were all had licenses and stuff
yeah so or they seem to have licenses I
think it was
legal but look like bars and nightclubs
yeah there were girls in there and
behind it was be like a open like a
little tiny looking like
a an
outdoor garden and then there'd be like
apartments on either side you know they
might be two stories tall and you
sometimes you know you like a like a
motel you know like a you know like an
apartment complex you know you went in
there and they they had a room you know
a bathroom and it was just normal it
like they're living in there right they
had these what tripped me out when I got
in there that first
time is they had these gigantic closets
here here in the west you know a closet
is something built into a wall you have
a door that goes into it it's part of
the house they don't have it like that
their closets are like a big like a big
like a wardrobe like a wardrobe and they
opened up and they looked they were
Korean as [__] it's kind of like black
and a red with I don't know Korean
symbols and handles on it and might be
dragons there's no telling what could
have been on it and they were huge they
were they they' go up almost to the
ceiling so it had big wood furniture in
there big beds colored
lights Black Walls you know and colored
lights and black and red and gold and or
could and then another girls her [__]
might all be like blue and silver and
and you know they I guess they lived in
there nightstands and look look like
just some girl's room yeah you know they
lived in
there now I don't know if they traded up
right they probably didn't live in the
same one all the time they probably was
like a hotel they probably she's
probably living in there that night they
probably traded it up
but I don't know I don't know they had a
closet in there it was probably all her
stuff in there I mean it would seem
easier if they would just stay in the
same place yeah and it just seemed like
a normal regular [__] and you I don't
even remember paying because they just
[__] pickpocket you like that take
the cash right out [__] put the
pocket wallet right in your pocket again
that's how good they were they fast yeah
no negotiation or anything just they
just took there yeah and count the
change and she didn't take everything
just oh that was probably about 50 bucks
okay right yeah
know they wanted to make it seem more
like a real experience
so they just like Yeah and I don't think
they took the same amount every time
they just depend on what they were going
to take from you whatever they needed
that day yeah I'm kind of I'm kind of
short this month I'm just I'm just gonna
take a little bit extra yeah they won't
know then that sh was over they [__]
walk down the club and then she byebye
[__] then she go off see you let's
get out of here your friends will be
with you you know right you be waiting
for somebody else to come out yeah he's
been there a long time come oh you guys
ready let's go then they go we go to
another one now it wouldn't wouldn't
necessarily be to hook up with girls
might just go to another one like we're
going to leave this in the past then
we'll go over this bar over here this
yeah yeah right yeah like this [__]
didn't
happen yeah yeah you look you look like
the cat like scraping [__] kitty
litter over the poop you know what I
mean like that kind of that kind of like
21 and some of the guys with me were
only like 18 19 yeah because you know
this is probably like the first time
they've had this well yeah if icking
remember the first time I went in there
I was with a guy he was about 19 he goes
man I never been never been to a place
like this yeah we're just talking about
it two girls just grabbed us they
[__] pull us out they're like oh okay
we didn't even choose
anything they was come on let's go
they're like hey quit standing around
they knew we were new time is money they
knew they knew we were new well yeah
they thought if they just like left you
to your own devices you just be like
standing around they probably overheard
what we said [__] around they're like
come on come on let's go we need some
money yep and [__] uh it was fine
man they all looked about the same they
were all good looking so it didn't
matter didn't matter whichever grabbed
you it was totally fine didn't matter
they well we pretty much all my friends
would [__] would agree that we didn't
pick them they picked us yeah if you
really want one to pick
you in that in that club type situ
because she picked you so it's her fault
it's her
fault well you know she wants to work
you're you're you're absolving yourself
of responsib well no that that's a funny
way of look at what it is is that she
picked you so therefore you know she
wants to work with you right if you
picked her there might have been a way
you might she might have been like not
like she didn't really want to be into
it she's like oh [__] this yeah I didn't
want this dude like picking me she like
oh well I guess I'm stuck with this one
right so you know that that didn't
happen so I guess they know that so
that's why they have that system yeah so
it's like it makes you feel more like
like yeah hey she picked me she picked
me right right yeah so it's like you
know that yeah she's not like reluctant
exactly like oh no exactly well some
didn't get picked oh okay they were
choosy well that's good at least other
places weren't but places like what
we're talking about that was the top end
yeah type stuff just CU you went in
there didn't mean no girls would work
with you yeah some of the girls be like
no they had hot guys to sho from no
thanks and you know you might get you
might get passed over and you'd have to
go to another place that's kind of
awesome yeah you know their time is
money and there's you know they were
outnumbered right yeah so it makes sense
actually to do it the other way around
yeah no there I think that's a better
system they're not sex machines like a
vending machine where you will get no
they're choosing who they're going to
work with right they're like look I got
to do this for money so I might as well
like pick somebody I want to do you guys
outnumber me 200 to one I'm going to
[__] pick the best ones the ones that
I want to work with so just be you know
total sense yeah Korea does not have
dating in the way that the West has the
closest thing to it would be those clubs
yeah yeah hookup
Club it's
interesting interesting the ones in the
window though that looked like something
like vending
machines yeah I have to say and you said
it wasn't like that back then but the
one and I'm assuming the shots B for
that it is a little weird I feel like
cuz I kind of some of the some of the
places in Amsterdam or like that too
which I always thought was a little
strange like I get it it's like a live
advertisement hooker Hill in the 1990s
was real naturalistic you just felt like
you were partying on the town
right and like I said I think that's
probably the best way to go about it it
makes it seem like less weird and less
transactional like you just seem like oh
I'm at this club and this chick dug me
so we went back ex right now some of
them were just like Saloon type bars and
the bartenders were also had side action
going on so you might have been talking
to three or four of them they're they're
serving drinks and one of them go come
on let's go come on let's go let's have
a good time yeah you're like yeah she's
all right we'll go with her you know
yeah yeah so that's also kind of like
being picked right yeah I get it yeah
all right
so you were you were uh anticipating two
hours we've now been on for three and a
half
hours so long show I mean yeah it's 11
but I guess people don't mind
cuz people are still here this [__]
nail key is breaking off and I keep
dropping it and I don't know where it
went to got a glue it bag on I know but
I can't see because it's too dark in
here all right so I guess we're going to
wrap it up because it's almost 11
o'clock yeah and I probably need to go
to sleep yep cuz I woke up very I woke
up at
5:30 cuz I had to pee and then I
couldn't really go back to sleep so I'm
just like laying there like man so I'm
very very tired I'm actually like
surprised I'm still awake yeah but you
know all right so thank you everybody
for dropping by this evening uh this was
actually uh a fun show even though it
was a [__] up topic so you know
hopefully you guys enjoyed it as well
remember to come back on Friday night
for our side track show where we don't
have a topic we just talk about whatever
the [__] we feel like talking about um
we're pro that might be a um pregame
show cuz I think we're going to momento
Mory on Friday night I think momentto
Mory is this week yeah so we'll see how
that goes but I'm you know I'm not sure
yet but we'll see and uh also remember
we have the sponsor affiliate thing now
so there's a link for audible in the
description box and if you click on that
you get 30-day free trial of audible and
we get a commission off that as well so
you know if you wanted to get audible
this is a good time to get it so we will
see you guys again on Friday night good
night